Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur neunzigsten Ausgabe hier unserer
Reihe, wir nähern uns der Hundert, wir nähern uns auch langsam dem zehnjährigen Jubiläum dieses Podcasts im Übrigen. Aber ein gewisser Weg ist noch äh zu gehen und heute nehmen wir den nächsten Schritt
Heute bin ich nach Heidelberg
gefahren und äh heute wird's staubig und ein bisschen dreckig, denn wir äh wollen mal schauen, was eigentlich im Universum noch so zu äh finden ist, was vielleicht nicht ganz so offensichtlich ist. Konkret geht es um,
den Weltraumstaub. Und dazu gibt's keinen besseren Gesprächspartner als meinen heutigen, nämlich über Hartgrün. Schönen guten Tag, Herr Grün.
Guten Tag. Herr Fritzlauf.
Ja
Wir sind äh in Heidelberg, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen auch der Kern ihrer äh ihrer ihres Wirkens äh zu Beginn gewesen. Wie äh wie heißt Heidelberg sie denn da geprägt.
Ja also ich bin aufgewachsen in einem kleinen Dorf im Oberhessischen, am Rande des Vogelsberges.
Äh und bis sechzehn Jahren bin ich dann nach Heidelberg gekommen, weil meine Großeltern hatten hier ein Haus gebaut, damals noch auf einer Kuhweide,
und das war während des Kriegs und Nachdems von den Amerikanern besetzt und wurde dort wieder freigegeben und da sind wir nach Heidelberg gezogen.
Und ich habe dort meine Schule absolviert, Abitur gemacht und äh Physik studiert.
Das war auch gleich klar, dass sie das wollten.
Ja und zwar ähm.
Ich selber erinnere mich nicht mehr dran, aber mir wurde gesagt, äh dass meine Großmutter äh mich gefragt hatte, als ich acht Jahre alt war, was ich werden wollte und da sagte ich Astrologen.
Weil ich immer fasziniert war in dem kleinen Dorf, war wunderschöner Sternenhimmel zu sehen, Meteore, Sternschnuppen äh sind über den Himmel gezicht und die Milchstraße war zu sehen,
am Abend, also um nachts, wenn ich nachts über die Wiese zum Bauer zum Milchhold gegangen bin und äh das hat mich äh beeindruckt. Ich war auch technisch interessiert,
mit meinem Opa der Maschinenbauinview war, der hat alle möglichen,
Dinge gebaut, kleine Häuschenhütten, selber ein Haus und eben das Haus in Heidelberg hatte er vorher schon gebaut, während er,
arbeitslos war weder Depression und das hat mich schon geprägt,
und als der Heidelberg kam äh und das Abitur machte, war es klar, dass ich Physik studiert wollte. Allerdings, damals war noch Wert, Wehrpflicht und ähm,
Das war ein Losverfahren, man zog ein Los, werden der äh.
Ein Berufungsprozesses und je nach Los äh die gingen bis ungefähr dreitausend,
da konnte man sehen, wann man eingezogen wird. Und die Leute, die über dreitausend hatten, also es ging noch viel weiter. Äh die hatten gute Chancen äh das Studium anzufangen und dann äh,
danach möglicherweise dann freigestellt zu werden. Aber ich hatte hundertfünfzig ungefähr und da war keine Chance und da habe ich gesagt, da da gehe ich gleich nach dem Abitur,
zur Bundeswehr und deswegen anderthalb Jahre.
Und als ich dann zurückkam, war ich allerdings bisschen außer Tritt mit dem Vorlesungs äh Terminen. Das war so ein Jahreszyklus und dann war ich in einem halben Jahr,
mittendrin, aber ich habe trotzdem dann äh mit dem zweiten Semester angefangen und das erste Semester praktisch dann hinterher nachgeholt,
mich vorbereitet. Das ging ganz gut. Also es war klar, dass ich Physik studieren musste, weil hier in Heidelberg konnte man nicht ähm,
mit Astronomieanfang erst nach dem Diplom als Physiker konnte man dann Astronomie machen. Und äh,
ich war,
war klar, dass ich explodal Physik machen wollte, das Basteln hat mir immer Spaß gemacht und so kam ich dann, habe ich hier angefangen und dann kam die nach vier Semestern hatte ich dann das Vordiplom in der Tasche,
Ähm was für eine Diplomarbeit, ich machen's könnte. Da war ganz äh im,
Trend ganz äh Laserphysik, die war ganz neu damals.
Welches Jahr ist das jetzt.
Das war dreiundsechzig.
Mein Studienkollege, mit dem ich zusammen dann äh war, der allerdings ein halbes Jahr vorher fertig wurde, der Theo Hensch, der ist bekannt, der es hat dann später einen Nobelpreis gekriegt,
auf eine Lasertechnik. Der war einer der der so eine Arbeit im physikalischen Institut bekommen hatte,
Da das nicht waren die ganzen Plätze besetzt und mich umgehört und dann hieß es im Max-Planck-Institut, da oben irgendwo auf dem Berg,
da machen sie Weltraumforschung ganz neue Gruppe und da bin ich hingegangen und.
Äh dort gleich nach dem Vordiplom machte man da ein Großpraktikum. Also wurde ich angenommen und ich kam in ein in die Staubbeschleunigergrupp.
Als ich ankam, gab's den Staubbeschleuniger nicht, aber er war schon bestellt und noch während der Zeit, also gleich nach einem Monat,
kam er an und das erste, was ich gemacht habe, die Abschirmsteine,
und Beschleuniger, der mit zwei Millionen Volt Staubteigen elektrostyrisch beschleunigt. Äh der gibt Strahlung ab und die muss dann durch äh Betonsteinen schwer betont, einem eine Mauer abgeschirmt.
Und das erste, was ich gemacht habe, solche Betonsteine da aufzubauen und den äh den Kasten um den Beschleuniger zu mach.
Warum würde den Staub beschleunigt.
Ja, das war.
Normalerweise wird er ja gesaug.
Ja äh das äh Institut des Max Plangens Social Kernphysik hatte und der Gentner der Gründungsdirek,
Abteilung, Kernphysikalische Abteilung, aber auch,
kosmochemisch Abteilung. Das ist eine Abteilung, in der Physiker im Wesentlichen, aber auch Chemiker äh,
kernphysikalische Methoden anwenden, um extra terroristisches Material zu untersuchen. Zum Beispiel Methyorit,
das war ganz interessant, woher kommen die, wie alt sind die? Äh woraus bestehen die? Äh und diese Abteilung,
gab's dann auch eine Gruppierung, die sich mit dem Kleinsten mit Thüriten, die gar nichts bis auf die Erde,
der die nicht sichtbar sind, jedenfalls nicht als einzelne Teilchen,
zu äh zu analysieren. Das war grad Beginn der Raumfahrt und eins der wesentlichen Fragestellungen war äh kann dieser Staub, diese Methode, die man äh,
sieht als Meteor, als Sternschnuppen, wenn sie ein Erdogan sehr eintreten und mit Geschwindigkeiten bis zu siebzig Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Eine Gefahr darstellen für die startenden Raumfahrzeuge.
Und äh das war die Fragestellung und.
Da hatte in Amerika im Russland also den Raumfahrenden, also US-Sessar damals noch,
Raumfahrenden Nation wurde haben sich Gruppen gebildet, die mit einem fasten Direktoren wie einfachen Mikrofonen versuchten den Staub nachzuweisen,
das Mikrofon geeignet ist, konnte man dadurch überprüfen, indem man einfach Glasperlen auf Mikrofon fallen ließ,
Und dann wusste, wusste man, Impuls und Energie er hat und was für Signale daraus kommt, der glaubte man, das kann man dann extra polieren zu den.
Kleineren Teilen,
die bis zu tausend Millimeter an mikrometergroß sind und solche Dinge wurden geflogen, andere Gruppierungen,
hatten dann versucht den Staub einzufangen, denn das war das Ziel, man wollte den Staub kennenlernen, wollte wissen, woraus besteht er und vielleicht was, wo kommen die denn her.
Sie haben jetzt erstmal auf der Erde beschleunigt, um irgendwie das zu simulieren sozusagen, um also äh eine eine Basis zu haben, nachzuvollziehen, wie sich der Staub im All verhalten könnte, um dann Instrumente reinzuhalten.
Ja und das war klar, also das war eine große äh Kontroverse im Augenblick, denn die andere Methode, wie man äh Staub untersuchen konnte, war von Astronomen oben auf dem Berg, der Elsässer,
so Elsa der Gründungsarek der Firmen MPE für Astronomie und seine Mitarbeiter Christoph Leinhardt und andere,
untersuchten das zu diaka Licht. Das ist ein Himmelsleuchten,
was man an einem klaren, dunksen Tag in der Abenddämmerung sehen könnte als so ein dreieckiges Leuchten am oberhalb der,
äh entlang der Egliptik, der also der Bahnebene, der Planeten, was schon Cassini, sechzehnhundertdreißig als Staub interpretiert hat im Weltraum,
von der Sonne angestrahlt ist und dann beleuchtet wird und dadurch sichtbar wird.
So eine dünne Staubscheibe, die die Sonne umgibt und die dann.
Die ja nicht die Sonne umgibt, sondern in der Ebene der Planeten ist.
Also zwischen den Planeten und der Sonne. Genau. Hm.
Interplanetarisch staub. Der da. Und zwar nicht nur morgens, auch abends abends und morgens ist es zur DRK zu sehen.
Wenn's denn klar genug und dunkel genug, was heute im Allgemeinen nur noch in in sehr abgelegenen äh Stellen.
Mhm. Mhm.
Ja, also die hatten dann schon eine Vorstellung, wie viel Licht streut da zurück und unter der Annahme der Größenverteilung dieser Staubteilchen, die äh.
Nicht gemessen worden war. Bis dahin äh konnte man sagen, wie viel Busse es da geben, um dieses Leuchten vorzogen.
Die andere Art war dann mit Instrumenten, die ich gesprochen habe, Mikrofon, dann.
Außerhalb der Erdatmosphäre zu fliegen und diese Staub dort direkt zu messen.
Die Kontroverse war, dass die Leute, die das Institu, also an eine Stelle mit mit Direktoren, den Staub registriert hatten, äh viel zu viel gesehen hatten. Das wurde diskutiert, gibt's einen Staubring um die Erde.
Und der und das konnten die Astronomen, der stand im Widerspruch, denn der hätte müsste man dann sehen von der Erde, auch als leuchtende Scheibe oder leuchtende Hintergrundhelligkeit.
Die war nicht zu sehen und es lag dann da dran, dass die Instrumente möglicherweise sehr unzuverlässig sein,
und wir als kernphysikalisches Institut hatten eben Möglichkeiten,
Tagesgeschäft war hier unten beschleunigen und dann irgendwelche krankphysikalischen Prozesse beim Aufeinandertreffen von äh Atom und Kernen festzustellen, konnte man dann auch Staub.
Beschleuniger brauchen, elektrostagische Beschleuniger, indem man den Staub auflegt und dann im elektrischen Feld,
einige Millionen Volt,
In unserem Fall war der Staubbeschleuniger zwei Millionen Volt, aber das Institut hat äh kernphysikalische Instrumente, die bis sechzehn Millionen Volt gegen.
Mhm. Und dann rotiert der äh Staub oder wie.
Na, der wird dann einfach äh beschleunigt vom also den Staubteilchen werden positiv aufgeladen. Ähm und äh.
Fliegen dann von der positiven Seite, von plus zwei Millionen Volt auf die Null Volt, das ist dann der Labor äh Potenzial und da kriegen sie Geschwindigkeiten im Kilometer bis hundert Kilometer.
Aber was für eine Strecke ist das dann, die man dann überbrück.
Der Beschleuniger selber hat so einen Meter Meter fünfzig Länge. Das ist die Beschleunigungsstrecke, die ist eben es ist natürlich im Vakuum.
Also ist jetzt nicht wie im Zern, dass man dann erstmal so einen Kilometertunnel gebohrt hat und das den Stopp auf weite Strecken, es geht einfach nur darum, ihn sehr.
Hätten wir gerne, aber das war leider nicht möglich und da war nicht das ja, also,
und äh solch ein Staubbeschleuniger, das war im Prinzip ein krankphysikalischer Beschleuniger, der allerdings dann eine Staubquelle hatte, die war das Besondere an der Staubquelle, das ist so ein kleiner Behälter, da liegt dann.
Als erstes, was mit dem er explodieren war Eisenstaub bei der Tonbandherstellung,
wird äh Eisen, das besteht aus kleinen äh Eisen, Kügelchen, die durch die Reduktion einer Eisenverbindung,
gewonnen wird als kleinste Kügelchen, Mikrometer große Kügelchen, das war wunderbar geeignet für uns dann, die wir da nicht auf dem Plastik äh Tape geklebt,
waren dann ein Thronband, sondern wir haben so ein Fläschchen gekriegt und,
Da liegt also eine kleine Schale, da drüber eine Zunge, an die eine Spannung angelegt wird und dann wird die oberste Schicht vom Staub angezogen,
und fliegt dann durch die Zunge, die Löcher hat dann in den eigentlichen Beschleunigungsraum hinein, in dem man,
Nadelsitz, die vorne an der äh Spitze eine sehr hohe Feldstärke hat, wenn dann zufällig da ein Staubteil hinten drauf kam, hat's eine besonders hohe Ladung gekrieg,
und dann durch das Feld in das Beschleunigungsrohr reingezogen. Das war die Staufquelle.
Das heißt, das funktioniert jetzt aber auch nur mit Staubpartikeln, die äh entsprechend manetisierbar waren.
Äh elektrisch.
Elektrisch leitend war.
Also Magnetis, das war klar mit Magnetiabeschleunigung kann man wie beim Zerren nicht äh arbeiten, da kriegt man die Energie nicht äh hin. Aber mit Elektrostatik beschleunigen äh ging das.
Und.
Hätte es jetzt auch so mit Steinpulver oder sowas äh funktioniert.
Jaiden,
Das haben wir später gemacht, allerdings der muss elektrisch leitend sein. Denn wenn er an diese Spitze drankommt, muss er falsch auf das Potenzial kommen, wenn sie einen Isolator nehmen, Glas,
sowas würde nichts passieren. Das wird nicht geladen und deswegen wird's nicht beschleunigt. Allerdings mit einem Trick, indem man diese Oberfläche beschichtet, die fest genug hält, dass das nicht wegfliegt, die Beschichtung,
kann man auch äh haben wir kontritisches Material, also Material, was aus dem meteoritisch dann,
oder auch Gesteinsmaterial, Olivien und so weiter äh beschleunigt. Denn im Weltraum gibt's halt nicht bloß Eisenpulver,
sondern alle möglichen im kleinen, zermahlenden Methode,
wobei Meteoritia äh das würde dann würden wir nicht sehr weit kommen. Meteorit besteht, also zumindestens mal die Kolidenkritte,
bestehen aus einer Mischung von allen Materialien, die es gibt, denn das ist das Ausgleichsmaterial, das aus dem Planeten entstanden sind,
Also da muss man dann schon gezielt von Minalogen äh spezielle Mineralien kriegen und die dann einzeln untersuchen, was die für ein Signal mach.
Aber in dem Moment ging's ja jetzt primär erstmal um die Entwicklung von neuen Instrumenten, wenn ich das richt.
Von neuen Instrumenten und vor allem von zuverlässigen Instrumenten. Denn man hat festgestellt, diese Mikrofone, die reagieren auf alles mögliche. Die reagieren auf Kosmetikstrahlung,
wenn man sie sehr schnell heißt, nicht die Zeranfelder, die man heute hat, sondern diese,
Platten früher, dann dann knackten die das, weil sich dann dies ausgedehnt haben,
und deswegen und ihr habt Umlauf läuft da ja so ein Satellit dauernd durch den Erdschatten, dann wieder in die Sonne und wird dauernd hochgeheißt, abgekühlt und so weiter und allein durch dieses hermensche Prozieren knackt das Ding dauernd.
Die kosmischen Strahlen, die da durchgehen, erzeugen auch Knackse. Deswegen das Fahrrad äh schnell klar, dass die sehr unzuverlässig sind,
in der Kernphysik atmen Methoden, Kurinzidenzmethoden, dass man nicht nur ein Signal nimmt, viel Wärmemikrofon, das gibt ein Schnack,
und dann denkt man, man hat irgendwas gemessen.
Kann aber auch halt einfach nur irgendeine andere Strahlung gewesen sein.
Störung sein.
Da haben wir Methoden entwickelt, die gleichzeitig in Amerika auch untersucht wurden und entwickelt wurden,
dass beim Auftreffen von Staubteilchen mit hohen Geschwindigkeiten so einen Kilometer pro Sekunde,
Material im das Staubteilchen selber, aber auch im Target, also der Oberfläche auf die es auftrifft,
Krater erzeugt wird und das Material, die Energie ist so hoch, dass das Teilchen verdampfen kann.
Aber nicht nur verdampfen, denn wenn ihr die Temperatur hochgenugst, dann mionisiert das auch. Also.
Atome oder Moleküle werden verlieren Elektronen,
und es gibt ein Plasma. Und dieses Einschlagsplasma war das der Prozess, mit dem wir Staubteilchen analysiert. Wir haben dann äh in einem dieses Amt über diese Einschlagsplatte,
auf die dieses Startgleichen auftreffen sollten im Labor, weil das einfach da im Strahlrohr endet hat man die an.
Leckeres Feld, durch ein Gitter, was man da vorlegt oder irgendein anderer Feldkonfiguration, kann man diese.
Elektrischen Teilchen separieren das Plasma, das hier auseinander äh trifft. Das ist ja wie eine Explosionswolke, die dann auseinandergeht und da,
äh Plasma besteht aus positiven äh geladenen Teiche meistens die Atomkerne und die Hüllen, die Resthüllen äh der also der Idionen und Elektroen. Und man kriegt zwei Signale.
Und damit hat man von einem Einschlag zwei Signale, die mehr oder weniger unabhängig sind voneinander. Und wenn man die ähm getrennt aufnimmt,
und dann noch sagt, die müssen zu.
Gleichzeitig innerhalb von Mykrosekunden, das Millionstel Sekunden müssen die gleichzeitig sein, dann war das ein Einschlag.
Kann es nur das gewesen sein.
Ist nur das gewesen.
Nicht dieses selbe Signal erzielen.
Genau, diese sogenannte Kurinzedenzmethode war dann der Durchbruch und solche Instrumente hatten wir entwickelt und die waren äh,
Auch in Amerika wurden solche äh äh Geräte kamen zum Einsatz und die haben zum ersten Mal erstmal viel niedrigere.
Einschlagsraten festgestellt, als die einfachen, simplen Direktoren,
und das war dann die Methode mit der man wirklich,
zuverlässig die Staubteilchen im Weltall messen konnte.
Wir hatten ja diese Messgeräte damals da hochgebracht, also.
Na ja, das war.
Dreiundsechzig, also. Äh fünfundsechzig. Fünfundsechzig?
Fünfundsechzig. Ja gut einundsiebzig war der Mond fa.
Gab's schon so ja.
Also Raketentechnik äh war gab's und äh die war auch im Institut. Wir hatten eine Gruppe, die Atmosphärenforschung machte und die obere Atmosphäre und die Jonoshäre untersucht,
Prozesse dort und da haben wir auch kleine Staubdeutel hier draufgebaut.
Also es wird quasi kleine Satelliten hochgeschossen, die.
Zunächst mal mit Höhenforschungsraketen.
Haben wir Direktoren, aber die sehr klein waren, so zehn Quadratzentimeter, also das ist.
Streichholzschachtelgröße. Die Sensoren und da hat man nichts gefunden, weil die Zeit, die Exponierungszeit.
Extra Rechtenstaub nicht groß ged.
Welcher Höhe wurden die dann ausgebracht? Also.
Ach so hundert Kilometern drüber und die Messzeit war auch begrenzt und das ist dann so ein Paralflug, das dauert ein paar Minuten, dann ist die vorbei,
Deswegen die waren nicht sehr erfolgreich oder nicht überhaupt nicht erfolgreich und man hat musste auf seine Litten dann gehen und da hatten wir das Glück.
Dass äh einer der ersten Satelliten, die die Esro, die heutige Esa.
Äh gebaut habe, war die Heosit.
Die im Wesentlichen auch von Gas hin betrieben wurde, von der Physik dort, äh die die Magnetosphäre untersuchen sollten.
Und da hatten die ein Instrument, äh was sie sehr erfolgreich betrieben hatten, aber damit war,
diese Wissenschaft beantwortet, die Fragen und es war Platz für die zweite Mission. Äh die andere Instrumente auch noch hatte, Manometer und so weiter. Ähm.
Ähm war ein Platz frei für ein äh ins zum Einstaubdirektor von uns vom Inspax Plans zu verkannen für sie. Und das auf dem Heos zwei Satelliten flogen, wir dann unseren ersten ähm.
Unseren ersten Staubdetektor ähm im Jahr neunundsechzig bekamen wir die ähm.
Dass wir da mitfliegen können, sagten wir, ja, machen wir und zweiundsiebzig vor dem Start, also sehr schnell innerhalb von drei Jahren war das Instrument zur Flugreife entwickelt.
Heliosatellit.
Heos, HEOS, High Excentric, Orbiting, Satellite, der ging bis auf ungefähr ein Drittel der Mondentfernung, im Wesentlichen äh war dazu da die,
Physik der Aurora, also.
Polare Lichtregion im Weltall der Magnotosphäre zu untersuchen, weil dort eben, wie gesagt, die Aurora, eine Himmelserscheinung,
äh sehr prominent war, die man erkunden wollte, wo was passiert denn da genau in der Atmosphäre? Und wie sieht die Magnusphäre.
Um die Erde geht und die Erde ist ja die Pole, ein ein magnetischer Depol und deswegen die äh Form praktisch die Magnusphäre und gerade an den.
Polemden äh gibt es besondere Magnetfeldkonfiguration, wo das Magnetfeld zusammenkommt und dann überm Aquator zum anderen Pol hingeht,
und auch das Plasma, was dann an das Magnetfeld gebunden ist, macht dort äh besondere Phänomene,
und diese Aurore Zorunen im in der Magnusphäre sollten untersucht werden. Deswegen hat man diesen Dreieck Orbit und Zettelleit, der ging bis auf,
hunderttausend Kilometer Höhe Boden, also ein Drittel der Mondentfernung ging ja durch dieses Auge zum und da hatten wir dann ein Staubinstrument des Instrument drauf.
Aus eben aus solchen einfachen Einschlagsionisationsdetektorbestand ähm.
Zwei Signale in Konsidenz den Einschlag wirklich identifizieren sollten. Ja, das war erfolgreich. Äh.
Der lief ja auch lange, also der war ja so.
Heros lief dann zwei Jahre.
Sieben Jahre. Also, als.
Denn die Bahn war so exzentrisch, dass jedes Mal, wenn die äh weit draußen war, dann gemacht die kleinsten Störungen, insbesondere vom Mond veränderten dann das,
Perry gehumsant von der Präsidentin kleinsten Abstand zur Erde. Und innerhalb von zwei Tagen wart etwa Jahren war er dann in der, ist es ein Etatsphä.
Aber innerhalb von zwei Jahren könnte man dann schon ganz gut messen und dann gab's das erste Mal quasi konkrete Informationen dadrüber, wie viel Staub kommt denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich in unserer Atmosphäre an.
Äh ja und in ähm.
In welchem Impact et cetera.
Ja. Also wir waren nicht die einzigen, die Amerikaner, ähm Gott als Base als Institut hatten die Pionier, sondern schon in Interplanetanraum, also weg von der Erde ähm äh geschickt und die hatten ähnliche Direktoren,
die,
auch im Interplantarot. Wir haben im erdnahen Raum äh gemessen und äh erste Mal zufällig äh bestimmt und die die Werte hier.
Flüsse, das ist also wie viel Teilchen pro Zeiteinheit pro Sekunde durch einen Quadratmeter durchfliegen ungefähr, die wir eine Million mal geringer als das, was diese Einfahrtdirektoren gesehen haben. Die.
Natürlich total falsch war, die einfach bloß das Rauschen, Störungen gesehen haben.
Das heißt, im Prinzip sind sie gleich vom Staat weg äh nachdem das Studium da so im Kasten oder war das noch Teil des Studiums, habe ich jetzt nicht so ganz äh mitbekommen. Da war das schon abgeschlossen, als sie in dieses äh Lab.
Also ähm ich mein ähm,
fünfundsechzig bin ich in die Gruppe gekommen äh zweieinhalb Jahre später hatte ich mein Diplom.
Und dann hab ich die Gelegenheit bekommen das Raum ein Raum in.
Instrument für die Helios-Sonde. Helios war ein deutsch-amerikanisches Projekt, das äh ähm,
Eine Raumsonde bis auf ein Drittel der Erdentfernung zur Sonne an die Sonne heranbringen soll.
Das habe ich äh achtundsechzig ähm angefangen.
Zu entwickeln.
Und mit dem Instrument soll nicht nur die Einschläge registriert werden im Interplantalraum, sondern möglichst auch noch ihre Zusammensetzung.
Denn bei diesem Einschlagsprozess, den ich ihnen beschrieben habe.
Werden die Jornen sind ja zum Teil aus dem Targetmaterial, das ist das, was wir aus dem wir den Desektor bauen an der Oberfläche. Wir haben da Gold genommen, weil das besonders rein sein sollte,
oder kein ist. Und äh bei dem Einsteig werden die Ironen dann außer Goldionen werden auch noch die,
Stoppt halt, die Jungen vom Stabteilchen sind drin und in einem Massenspektrometer und das ist auch wieder eine kranphisikalische Methode, die wir an dem Institut hatten,
ein Flugzeitmassenspektometer konnte man dann aus die Masse der Juden bestimmen. Da kann man die verschiedenen Elemente,
die kommen dann zeitlich nacheinander. Also Flugzeitmassenspektometer ist so beim Einschlag entstehen die Ionen ja ganz kurze Zeit und wenn man sie dann in einem Feld beschleunigt, sagen wir tausend Volt.
Dass die alle tausend Elektronen Volt beschleunigenergie haben, dann fliegen die also alle mit derselben Energie zum selben Zeitpunkt ab,
und da sind die Kleinen hier mit der niederen Atommasse äh sind schneller an dem,
Nachweisdirektor im Elektronikmultiplayer, als die schweren und so unterkriegt man ein Laufzeitspektrum der Jungen. Das war das Ziel von Helios. Und dieses Instrument habe ich in meiner Doktorarbeit entwickelt.
Äh pronoviert habe ich äh siebzig, neunzehn, siebzig, also zwei Jahre, das war eine relativ kurze ähm.
Produktion zeigt und dann waren äh war ich gleich Teilnehmer an dem Helios Projekt. Das war keine Ausschreibung, das war von der Politik.
Besprochen, dass Deutschland zusammen mit den Amerikanern eine große Weltraummission machen wollte,
und unser Instrument war ein Staubinstrument und vom Max Blankens hat für Astronomie gab's ein Zoodiaka-Lichtfotometer, das jetzt mit optischen Methoden den Staub,
im Sonnensystem messen sollte. Also es gab zwei Staubinstrumen.
Kurz mal einhaken. Also wir befinden uns jetzt ungefähr so Mitte der siebziger Jahre, ne.
Vierundsiebzig von Helio.
Genau und das bedeutet, die Raumfahrt äh hat jetzt so
sagen wir mal so, ihr erstes äh solides Jahrzehnt äh abgelegt mit einigen äh Erfahrungen gesammelt, aber es gab ja noch sehr viele Unbekannte äh da draußen, also trotz der Erfolge und und dann und so weiter äh gab's ja auch viel, was man nicht äh wusste, gehörte sozusagen, da der
dieser Staub so noch so ein bisschen zu den Mysterien oder weil man mit diesen ersten Ergebnissen hatte man da schon so ein ein solides Wissen, mit dem man irgendwie gut arbeiten konnte.
Also nachdem zuerst diese falschen Messungen, die zu viel, viel zu viel Staub vorhersagt.
Da waren, haben die Amerikaner im Zusammenhang mit der ähm.
Vorbereitung für die Apollo Mission haben sie gesagt, damit das können wir den Astronauten dem nicht aussetzen, das müssen wir genauer wissen und deswegen waren die ersten Saturnre,
die erst die kleineren Saturn eins und zwei. Später war es ja die große Saturn fünf,
die wurden in Erdumlauf geschickt und dort wurden Tennisplatzgroße äh Direktoren geflogen,
die allerdings nicht auf diese kleinen Staubteilchen, die wir mit unseren Instrumenten messen, sondern auf den Größeren, die dann wirklich gefährlich dienende äh ein Zentimeter Aluminium durchschlagen können,
untersuchen konnten und die waren viel unempfindlicher und deswegen waren die auch nicht so störanfällig wie diese Kleinen und die hatten gezeigt, dass da so wenig da ist, dass man den,
ähm Weltraumflug, auch bemannten Weltraumflug ohne größere äh Risiken betreiben kann.
Also da hat noch genug andere Risiken, aber das war zumindest erstmal.
Das war äh das war so gut eingrenzt. Deswegen war die Gefährdung äh das Gefahrenpotenzial vom Staub war weg damit.
Aus den Köpfen erstmal.
Aus den Köpfen und aus ja aus dem Weltraumagenturen, die haben dann das nicht mehr groß gefordert. Wenn am Anfang gab's insgesamt auf der Welt meisten Amerika äh zehn Staubbeschleuniger,
außer einen in Heidelberg, einen anderen in Cantabury in England und dann die anderen acht waren USA, die dann benutzt wurden, u,
Staubinstrumente zu entwickeln und zu Eichen. Äh und die Finanzierung war für die amerikanischen,
bis auf eine Gruppe weg im Gottes Baseball-Center gab's noch eine. Und zu der bin ich nach meiner Provokation,
gab's im Rahmen von Helios ein sogenanntes Trainingprogramm, das Wissenschaftler, die am Helios beteiligt waren. Ähm.
Nach USA zu Gruppen gehen konnten, die sowas schon äh länger machten und dort äh Erfahrungen zusammen. Da bin ich mit meiner Familie äh rüber äh geflogen für ein Jahr auf einundsiebzig bis zweiundsiebzig.
Und hab bei Odo Berg, der im Gotter Space Platz Center diese Pionierinstrumente äh geflogen hat.
Eben mit der Datenauswertung äh mitgemacht. Und es war gleichzeitig äh die Vorbereitung für ein Staubexperiment auf dem Mond,
aus der Ottoberg dann äh mit Apollo siebzehn hochgeflogen hat. Äh das lief dann gerade im Labor und da war ich mit dabei, das war,
äußerst interessante Sachen. Wir sind da auch nach Juston gefahren, haben dann einen Astronautentraining beobachtet, die dann das Ausbringen der Instrumente auf,
den Mond später üben sollten und das ist ja eine komplizierte Sache. Da musste erstmal die ähm.
Energiequelle, das waren radioaktive Generatoren ausgebracht werden, weit ab von Instrument, weil die ja ziemlich gestrahlt haben und dann die Leitungen legen, die Instrumente ausbauen, ausricht,
und das alles sicherstellen, dass dann die funktionierten und zu einer einer Sendestation, die dann die Daten zum Erde zurücksenden sollten. Das haben sie geübt.
Aber wenn jetzt sozusagen das Interesse am Staub erstmal als Bedrohungspotential so äh in den Keller gegangen ist und eigentlich nur noch so eine Minimalforschung hör übrig blieb, gewisser Hinsicht, zumindest nur noch an wenigen äh Standorten,
Was war dann,
eigentliche Ziel oder was was wollte man herausfinden oder worüber wissen wollte man sich gewahr werden, also was war das unmittelbare Ziel dieser Forschung?
Ja, also das ist ganz klar bei uns im Institut war es,
die Objekte selber, die äh zu verstehen, woher kommen sie, woraus bestehen sie? Die Mikromethoite, die großen Methode hat man da schon untersucht, man hat festgestellt, Kollegen von mir am Institut,
Hans Alter von einzelnen Körnern in Methoriten festfällt vier Komma sechs Milliarden Jahre,
und das ist das Alter des Planetensystems. Da ist das Zusammenkommen. Das konnte man aus Meteoriten finden, aus die die Materialien, die ich sage, Sprache von Contrit,
Das ist eine Mischung von allen Materialien, die es auf der Erde gibt, die zwar in der Erde schon verändert wurden, aber das war das Ausgangsmaterial.
Also es wechselte quasi von so einem potenziellen Problem für die Raumfahrt, also sagen wir mal, eher so ein technischer Asp,
hin zu der reinen Wissenschaft mit okay, alles klar, jetzt sind wir in der Lage, diesen Staub einzufangen, wir sind auch in der Lage mit
bestimmten Instrumenten den zu bestimmen, nicht wahr durch diese äh Massen äh
Spektruk Spektrum durch die Laufzeit konnte man schon mal rausfinden, was ist denn da eigentlich, aber damit hat man ja noch nicht so die komplette Chemische Zusammensetzung und Größe und so weiter, nähert sich dem an, aber,
war wahrscheinlich noch einiges zu holen, nämlich an.
Ja, ja, gut, also das waren der ersten Versuche und äh bei Helios hatten wir eine Massenauflösung von.
Zehn im besten Fall. Das heißt.
Das ist ein Verhältnis der Breite einer einzelnen Massenlinie zu äh.
Der Masse, die dabei ist. Also Masse zehn konnte man von Masse neun atomwahre Masseeinheiten.
Also zehn, weiß gar nicht, was das ist, aber zwölf ist Kohlenstoff.
Kohlenstoff konnte man vom Bohr und Lithium, das sind Elemente, die in der Gringe. Aber die hören und insbesondere die Moleküle, Magnesium vierundzwanzig, Aluminium siebenundzwanzig Schwefel, Eisen sechsundfünfzig,
nicht trennen. Also die ersten Helios,
hat man jetzt noch keine chemische Analyse kriegt man. Sah, dass es aus verschiedenen, dass verschiedene Zusammensetzungen gab,
Wir haben die identifiziert als solche, die ähnlich sind wie unsere Eisenteilchen, die wir im Labor untersucht hatten, äh dann andere, die aus,
simulierten damals noch äh,
kontritischem Material, also mehr silikatischem Material bestanden und dann anderen, die man nicht identifizieren kann. Also deswegen, das erste war noch kein Massenspektrum, mit dem man was viel anfangen konnte.
Zehn ist Neon.
Aha, danke schön.
Ja und Neon wer sowieso kommt nicht vor, das ist ja ein Edelgas und deswegen war das nicht ja äh heute arbeitet man die modernsten Massen.
Analysatoren gehen bis über hundert und es gibt Ideen bis zu zehntausend zu gehen. Das ist wichtig, wenn man,
ähm isomäre feststellen will auf der gleichen Masse liegen, die also gerade bei Molekülen, also sie aus verschiedenen äh atomaren Bestandteilen besteht äh.
Aber die gleiche Masse haben, die man mit dem einfachen Massenspektrum.
Bis Maße hundert äh noch auftrennen kann, aber dann liegt auf einer Masse jetzt verschiedene andere Massen. Äh weil gerade kein gutes Beispiel ein, aber äh das.
CO zwei äh zum Beispiel ist vierundvierzig, aber Masse vierundvierzig kann auch noch durch ander.
Moleküle erzeugt werden. Das kann man dann nicht mehr unterscheiden. Aber mit zehntausend kann man das sehr wohl.
Alles klar, verstehe. Ähm okay, worauf ich so ein bisschen hinaus will, ist so wie hat sich quasi die Sicht der Wissenschaft,
in der Phase auf diesen Staub entwickelt. Also als, als wie wichtig hat man das wahrgenommen? War das nur so ein Randas
oder hat man schon geahnt, da könnte viel Interessantes äh schlummern. Ich meine, es gab ja zu dem Zeitpunkt
so viele andere Dinge, die irgendwie alle auch erstmal erforscht und angestrebt werden wollten und manchmal dauert's ja eine Weile, bis so ein bestimmtes Feld überhaupt erst äh besonders äh in den Fokus des Interesses gerät.
Das ist richtig, also mit Helios und Helios von unserer Seite, aber ähnlicher Dinge gab's auf amerikanischer Seite und Engländer waren auch noch äh beteiligt, aber das waren auch meistens dann Zusammenarbeitungen.
Zwischen den Beteiligten und interessierten Gruppen ähm.
War gezeigt worden, man kann Staub besten. Was wir bei durch diese Instrumente außer.
Chemie war noch weit weg, aber grobe Zusammensetzung aus verschiedenen Kategorien von äh Zusammensetz konnte man unterscheiden. Aber noch nicht so, dass man äh.
Sehr genaue Analysen machen konnte. Das wäre das, wenn man das konnte, dann das hat zum Beispiel verzögert, dass die,
Kometen Mission zu wo wir man weiß, dass außerdem Eis und dem Gas, was vom Kameten wegfließ,
Staub weggeht und äh größerer Pock, die man analysieren möchte und von den man alles Mögliche wie die genaue Zusammensetzung, das Alter, wann ist das zusammengekommen, wissen wollte.
Äh das hat, da wir das noch nicht konnten, hat das die ersten äh Kometenmissionen verhindert,
sodass die sollten zwar wurden untersucht und ich war schon einundsiebzig zweiundsiebzig, also Amerika war bei den Mission der Missionsanalysen der NASA dabei, aber.
Insbesondere der Staub noch nicht so richtig untersucht werden konnte, äh wurde das dann nicht wurde nicht ausgewählt. Das kam erst.
Mit dem Hellisch und Kometen,
äh sechsundsiebzig, der sechsundsiebzig an der Erde in an der durch das innere Sonnensystem flogen ist, auf seinem Perhill äh Durchgang ähm.
Das war ein erklärtes Ziel, der Weltraumagenturen dorthin zu fliegen und äh Analysen zu machen.
Und natürlich die großen Weltraumnationen, Amerika, Russland,
aber auch Europa waren interessiert das zu machen, Japan dann auch. Und ähm da hat ähm.
Amerika war so praktisch die Nase war Vorreiter, die wollten eine große Mission äh zu einem jetzt nicht zum Direkt machen. Äh.
Am Helly vor mit einer Sonde am mit einer und abtrennbaren Sonde am Helle vorbeifliegen,
Weil der Helli sehr schnell durch das Sonnensystem, dem man nie äh an dem man nie andocken könnte oder ein Rohrdevoug machen konnte, sondern nur an vorbeiflog.
Aber zum Tempel kommt mit einem Tempel zwei war das Ziel, dort im Umlauf zu gehen und den genauer zu untersuch,
und die Esa sollte dann diese Vorbeiflug äh Mission für die am Helly machen.
In einem gemeinsamen Projekt.
Äh das wurde dann aber aus Kostengründen äh von Amerikaner gegrenzelt, weil andere Dinge wichtiger waren.
Äh und äh dann hat die Esa kurz entschlossen, gesagt, jetzt bauen wir nicht bloß eine Sonde, die abgestoßen wird vom Raumverzeug, sondern wir bauen eine eigene Sunde. Und das war dann die Jotte Sonne.
Also die Esa hat Jotto gemacht, die.
Russen haben eine Venusmission so modifiziert, dass sie an einem hellischen Kombeten vorbei sind. Das waren die Vega-Mission, Vega eins und zwei.
Japaner da hatten Mission geplant, die in großen Abstand verla.
Die Amerikaner haben dann allerdings einen Trick gemacht mit der ICE Mission. Das war eine.
Der Sospherische Mission und Sonnenwindmission, die sie schon Ende der.
Siebziger Jahre achtundsiebzig oder so gestartet, ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Und die dann äh den.
Weltraum untersucht hat auf äh das Sonnenwind, auf die Magnesosphärischen Einflüsse und so weiter. Und die war dann noch im Betrieb und die konnten sie umlenken durch ähm.
Vorbeiflüge an der Erde, so, dass sie dann auch an.
Äh Nähe vom höllischen Komet, allerdings in großer Entfernung. Dort ist bis auf neunhundert Kilometer, soweit ich das weiß, rangekommen. Die Vega sollten auf dreitausend Kilometer oder so.
Japaner bis auf hunderttausend Kilometer und die Amerikaner bis auf einige Millionen Kilometer.
Also im Prinzip haben diese Phase in den achtziger Jahren hat halt das war quasi eine neue Phase.
War absolut.
Angefangen mal so richtig sich den Staub äh anzuschauen, einfach auch aus der Motivation heraus, weil man einfach vermutet hat oder ja im Prinzip weiß
Wenn man in irgendeiner Form in die Vergangenheit schauen möchte und Erkenntnisse darüber bekommen möchte, wie wie
die Materialien sich halt früher mal im Universum oder zumindest zur Entstehung des äh Sonnensystems ähm angefühlt haben und beschaffen waren, dann sind das sozusagen die ersten Kandidaten, wo man mal nachschauen kann.
Genau. Äh also das war von erstmal so hohem wissenschaftlichen Interesse, dass man gleich von Anfang an äh Staubinstrumente als wesentliche Paylot betrachtet hatte für diese Raumfahrzeuge,
und da war jetzt diese.
Massenspektrometischen Instrumente, die wurden von meinem Kollegen Jochen Kissel am Institut. Max-Minze.
Entwickelt und der hat diese Instrumente ähm.
Äh sowohl auf Jotto als auch auf den Vegason geflogen und die haben äh erstmalig äh wirklich chemische Informationen zurückgebracht,
ähm zum Beispiel, dass man feststellen konnte, dass die leichten Elemente.
In dem Staubteilchen äh deutlich erhöht waren gegenüber das, was man in Metheriten gefunden hat, dass man sagen konnte, die.
Kometenstaub.
Enthält viele mehr leichte Elemente, das geht bis zum Kohlenstoff hoch, also selbst Wasserstoff in gebundener Form natürlich,
äh als die das, was wir von Meteoriten äh,
kannte und deswegen äh wusste man die Metare Material ist primitiver ursprünglicher, denn mit Thorite, die ja schon eine lange Geschichte haben, ähm,
bis man sie dann schließlich auf der Erde findet ähm haben auch bei ihrer Entstehung, bestehen sie aus äh,
deutlich stärker prozessierten Material. Die Idee ist die, dass die Kometen ja von einem großer Entfernung dem Kolpergürtel, also außerhalb,
oder irgend ungefähr in der Plutobahn außerhalb der Neptun äh Bahn,
gibt es denn eine Anhäufung von Objekten, die dann durch Störungen der Planeten,
abgelenkt werden, zum Teil weggestreut werden intergeleitischen Raum oder zum anderen Teil nach innen gestreut und dann die sogenannten Zentauren bilden, die dann von einem Planeten.
Äh Bahn durch den Vorbeiflug an Planeten gestreut werden wieder und teilt dann schließlich im inneren Sonnensystem ankommt, bis sie dann,
praktisch im Endzustand, also jetzt diese größeren Kilometer großen Kopf als Jupiter Family Kometen.
Ähm häufig mit Umlaufbahnen von,
entsprechende äh Jubitarplan von fünf bis sechs äh Jahren immer wiederkehren,
und damit äh sind's diese Kometen ein Ziel für die Kometenmission Tempel zwei zum Beispiel war so eine. Und jetzt auch der Zielplanet von.
Solche äh Komed.
Also diese und während der Helle noch einer ist, der hat noch Verbindung zu dem Ursprung, diesem Körper wird der fliegt bis zum Ornus raus in seiner größten Entfernung. Aber der Komplus als sechsundsiebzig Jahre ins innere Sonnensystem, das wir war,
neunzehnhundertsechsundachtzig die Gelegenheit, dass man einen Kometen jetzt und den man schon lange kannte, den man ja schon äh.
Glaub, dass die selbst die Chinesen schon vor Christian gesehen haben. Also kompetenten Beobachtungen, die äh aufgeschrieben wurden,
das hat man geguckt, dass da wahrscheinlich einer davon sogar schon helli war.
Gib mir Gelegenheit kurz auf eine vergangene Episode von Romzeit zu verweisen, weil zu Jotto und dann auch Setta äh Ausgabe zwanzig. Schon ziemlich lange her, habe ich mich mit Gerhard Schweben, den sie sicherlich,
kennen äh lange darüber unterhalten, wie diese Mission so zusammen äh gestellt worden ist, was so die Pläne und Ziele äh waren.
Das mal so äh nebenbei.
Ja. Also der.
Ihre Rolle in dem in der in der Juttomission.
Äh äh ich sagte mein Kollege, Jochen Kissel, der war für diese großen Massenspektrum in Staub analysiert,
zuständig, sowohl auf Jotto Weger. Äh ich war beteiligt mit äh Tony McDonald's aus Kentaburry, der äh das sogenannte.
Äh Instrument gebaut aus dem aus dem äh,
Schutzschild, der vor der Jotto-Sonde war, denn äh Jotto, das Raumfahrzeug.
Auf den Kometen zu.
Wirk auf den Kometen zu und durch die dichten Teile der Staubwolke, die vom äh Komet äh ausging und zwar mit Geschwindigkeiten von neunundachtzig Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Sind äh Geschwindigkeiten, die man mit keiner.
Laborinstrument, äh, simulieren kann. Man konnte nur durch Berechnungen, Aussagen, dass man ein Schutz.
Troffen werden möchte.
Man nicht davon getroffen wird, ist sicher,
und deswegen hat man ein Schutzhild gebaut, der so Ausrecht war, dass beim Vorbeiflug, der immer nach vorne zeigt, also die Staubteilchen äh sie vom Kometen ausgehen, mit kleiner Geschwindigkeit, aber die Haup,
äh Geschwindigkeitskomponent kommt von vorne da, wie wenn sie mit dem Auto durch den,
kommen die Stabilen auch von vorne und da wurde ein Schutzschild von einigen Zentimeter gebaut und zwar ein doppelter Schutzhit, ein erster den die Staubteiche auftreffen und der ist.
Entfernt von dem eigentlichen Raumfahrzeug, sodass die Staubteilen, die selbst da noch durchdringen, aber die werden dadurch durch den,
Wechselwirkung mit dem Schild zerlegt in Teile und dann gibt's das auch, verteilt sich die Splitter oder was da noch rauskommt. Auf einen großen Teilbereich, der lässt sich leichter abfangen. Also diesen doppelten sogenannten Wippelschild,
der wurde bei diesen Missionen,
gebraucht bei diesem Vorbeiflugmission, diese hohe Geschwindigkeit. Und diese Schutzschild, der wurde von Ton McDonald mit Instrumenten bestückt,
die Einschläge auf den Direktor. In dem Fall auch wieder Mikrofone, aber in dem Fall war es klar, denn äh.
Die Störer.
Nicht mehr ist, man wollte nur wissen, dass sie da sind.
Ja ja.
Aber die Rate war so viel höher als die Untergrund der durch andere Störungen kam. Das dann dadurch sehr äh zuverlässige Messeton. Und da gab's ein kleines Instrument drauf,
was für die Mikrometer großen Teilchen äh zuständig waren. Das war da auch drauf. Und das war mein Teil, was zusammen mit den Italienern,
gebaut hab und dann da geflogen hab.
Wie lange entwickelt man an so einem Instrument.
Das ging relativ schnell, aber das waren äh ja auch drei Jahre dann von der Idee.
Gut.
Und ein ein Duplikat wurde auch von Russen gebaut, denn ich hab das freiwillig frei ausgetauscht mit dem, also diese internationale Community, Wissenschaftskomödie war damals,
also vor dem Fall der sogenannten Eisen äh Vorhangs ähm.
War sehr freundschaftlich. Wir waren heute die Kollegen aus der ganzen Welt praktisch, ist man gute Bekannte und zum Teil Freunde. Und so haben wir den Russen unsere äh.
Zeichen.
Heute auch noch so.
Ja, ja, natürlich ist es heute so, aber das war damals noch vor äh.
Zu Zeiten, wo man so nicht unbedingt damit gerechnet hätte, war es schon.
Und das war ja toll, also sechsundsiebzig beim Vorbeiflug waren,
hat gab's eine große Konferenz, eine Helly Konferenz äh hier in Heidelberg, die wir veranstaltet hatten,
da waren die Kollegen hier bei uns im Haus und wir haben da gefeiert und uns gefreut und wirklich sehr äh gute, kollegiale Verhältnisse gehabt.
Ja, diese internationale äh Kooperation, also dieses dieses internationale Verständnis, was so in gewisser Hinsicht so eine, so eine Normalität auch darstellt
Ähm ich hatte im Raumzeit zwölf, habe ich mich mit Sigmund Jähn unterhalten
kam das äh sehr zur Sprache und das war dann auch so ein bisschen so die äh Erkenntnis, dass eigentlich diese ganze wissenschaftliche Kooperation Raumfahrt.
Auch so ein bisschen so ein Modell ist, so ein Zukunftsmodell, wie ich finde, so für die für die Gesellschaft, so wie es halt eigentlich laufen könnte. Dem der Rest leider nicht unbedingt immer in dem Maße folgt, wie es wünschenswert wäre, aber zumindest wird's da halt auch aktiv gelebt.
Ja, ja und äh.
Zwar gibt es gewisse Nationalismen, wenn's ums Geld geht, dann äh wird da schon von den insbesondere von den Geldgebern den nationalen Behörden drauf geachtet, dass die Eigenleute bevorzugt werden und die anderen,
Nicht so aber selbst das äh wie gesagt äh.
Deutsche Instrumente sind auf dem russischen Sonnen geflogen, mit Amerikanern sowieso und bei der ESA ist das ein internationales äh Community, die da mitmacht.
Ja und da auf der ISS haben sie alles zusammengesteck.
Ja äh übrigens den Gerhard Schwem haben sie erwähnt, das war ein Kollege, mit dem wir sehr äh eng zusammengearbeitet haben,
der war in Bochum beim äh Richard Giese in der Abteilung die Modelle für das zu dir Karlich gemacht haben. Und dann bei äh gab's die Möglichkeit, ähm.
Neunzehnhundertsiebenundsiebzig die.
Out of Ecliptic Mission, denn einer Zusammenarbeit zwischen Esa und NASA. Das sollte mit einer gemeinsamen Staat vom Space.
Äh Shuttle ein zwei Sonden gestartet werden mit eigenen Antrieben,
Die eine sollte über den Nordpol der Sonne gehen und die andere über den Südpol der Sonne,
das ist die Mission, die wurde dann später, nachdem die Amerikaner sich zurückgezogen hatten, von der einen Sonde, weil sie sagten, na ja, also die Politiker sagten das,
äh wenn's eine gibt, das muss ja reichen, denn die kommt dann nach einem halben Umlauf dann auch auf den anderen Teil der Sonne. Aber die Gleichzeitigkeit ging natürlich verloren. Und die Instrumente, die waren nicht äh,
äh genau identisch, sondern ähm auf der NASA-Sonde war ein.
Zur DRK-Lichtfotometer, also ist wieder das Helligkeit des Staubes, im Interplatarenraum messen sollte, was von,
äh wo die Bochumer Gruppe Gieße, Schweden beteiligt war, eingebaut werden sollte und auf der europäischen War ein Instrument von uns, wo ich dann äh leidende Wissenschaftler war.
Nachdem die amerikanische Sonde ausgefallen war, haben wir die äh Kollegen von Bochum mit,
als Teil unseres Teams mit aufgenommen.
Heißt, dass man äh mal ganz bewusst mal raus aus dieser Scheibe wollte, um da mal zu schauen, was da eigentlich so ein Staub ist, weil das man quasi so in in der Ekliptik, also da wo alle Planeten sich
ja nicht nur befinden, sondern auch geformt haben und der Astrid-Gürtel rotiert, dass das da viel zu holen ist, ist ja irgendwie klar und offensichtlich lässt sich auch messen nur was es quasi mit dem Rest oben und unten.
Nicht wahr?
Das war die Motivation Staubinstrument. Natürlich die Hauptmodilation war die Sonne von den Polen beobachtenden Sonnenwind dann in höheren Breiten, denn äh.
Einfach mal einen anderen Blick kriegen, ja?
Aber der Staub war dort auch eine wichtige äh Teil.
Und das wusste man dann, also ich meine, was hat man dann da gefunden.
Ja und das war dann für das unser Staubinstrument, also wie man das überhaupt gemacht hat. Zwei Sonnen.
Die äh in dem Fall als es Olises war nur noch eine, die Esersonde. Äh die sollte mit dem Shuttle äh hochgebracht werden, von dort aus mit einer eigenen ähm.
Wasserstoff, Sauerstoff getrieben, Rakete äh zum Gebitter geschickt werden. Nach dem Shuttle Challenger und Glück ähm.
Sechs und achtzig war ähm.
Kam das ganze Space Shuttle System zum Halt,
Raketen oder die Satelliten und zwar nicht nur Olysis, sondern noch sogar vorher die Galeriosonde, auf der wir dann auch ein Instrument hatten. Die waren schon am Cape.
Und das wurde dann eingemottet und ähm.
Also Cape Cannabis, der Stadtplatz der Amerikaner. Mhm.
Äh und konnte dann erst drei Jahre später fliegen, allerdings nicht.
Ja jetzt dann nicht mehr mit einer ähm Wasserstoff-Sauerstoff angetriebenen Raketesonne, mit einer Feststoffrakete, die einfach sicherer war gegen.
Explosion. Also die wurden dann äh neunundachtzig neunzig Leo neunundachtzig und äh neunzig äh gestartet.
Von der Erde aus, aber von der Erde aus über die Polen der Sonne war, ist nicht möglich, aber da hatte man schon äh äh schon entwickelt die Methode durch vorbeiflog, an Planeten die Bahn so abzulenken,
dass sie dann ganz andere Bahnen.
Emanöver.
Und und da war ist natürlich der stärkste Planet für solche Ablenkspanne ist der Jupiter,
also die Sonde und musste zum Geburtstag fliegen und dort abgelenkt werden, sodass sie dann auf dem Rückweg wieder ins Innovation sind, über die Pole der Sonne äh erst über Nordpol und dann.
Da reicht der Einflyberei aus? Mhm.
Reicht ein Pflege aus, ja. Äh ging dann allerdings sehr dicht äh an der am Jubität vorbei.
Dort wo die vorher die Pionier und Volja Sanden äh durchaus auch Staub festgestellt haben.
Also hat man sich da auch der Risiko ausgesetz.
Risiko, aber das ging alles gut und äh es kam dann und das Ergebnis vom Staub her war, dass beim Anflug an den Jupiter,
Während wir so der normalen von der Erde aus langsam abnehmen, der Staubraher hatte festgestellt haben und am Juppe der plötzlich sahen wir, dass die kleinsten Signale, die alle Charakteristiker von Einschlagszitaten hat.
Plötzlich in Gruppen von äh Auftraten erhöhten Häufigkeiten alle vierzehn Tage in so was man im Inneren sonst eben überhaupt nicht kannte.
Die Frequenz blieb gleich, also ungefähr vierzehn Tage äh aber die ähm.
Äh die Anzahl in den Pulsen nahm mit dem Abstand zum Jubiläum dazu. Das musste also ein Jupiter-Phänomen mähen sein.
Und das haben wir dann schließlich rausgekriegt, dass ähm,
durch die Idee war dann mit dem Kollegen Holz Zuck vom Johnson Space Center,
dass das kleine Staubteilchen sind, die vom Jupiter ausgehen und man hatte vorher mit den schon äh.
Die Vulkane auf dem Mond IO gesehen, wo man richtig sieht, dass da Staubwolken hochgehen, die zum Teil wieder runterfallen auf den äh auf die äh Jupiter Satelliten-Io,
und da war dann die Idee, die wir zusammen entwickelt haben mit Kollegen.
Gregor Morphil hier von aus Garching und Mihay Horani aus Bolda, dass das kleine Staubteilchen sind jetzt nicht mehr im Mikrometerbereich, sondern im Nanometerbereich. Also Milliardstelmeter.
Dass die dann, wenn sie geladen sind, das war immer die Vermutung, dass Staub im Weltraum allein schon durch die Wechselwärme mit dem Sonnenwind Plasma und mit der UV-Strahlung der Sonne, der Voll-Effekt davon,
Ladung haben müssten, aber es war bisher nie gelungen, die Ladung festzustellen.
Aber wie wie so vierzehn Tage. Das ist ja nicht die Rotation des Mondes. Die ist glaube ich.
Also es gibt zwei äh zwei Phänomene, die eine vierzehntägige Periode haben. Die beiden wurden diskutiert. Das eine ist der Sonnenwind. Die Sonne dreht sich einmal achtundzwanzig Tagen. Äh.
Um sich selber,
und der Sonnenwind, der durch die neutrale Schicht äh der Sonne, das ist eine Schicht, die am Sonnenequator äh ist, der die da ausgetreiben im Sonnenwind.
Positive Polarität von Nordpol und die negativen Südpol haben, je nachdem wie die Sonne gepolt ist, die ändert sich ja alle elf Jahre, dann ist die Polarität und dass dieser Sonnenwind, der ist, der.
Zum Sonnenäquator geneigt ist,
dass so eine gewölbte Schicht, die alle vierzehn Tage sich ändert. Die Polarität im Sonnenwind wechselt alle vierzehn Teilen. Also der,
Sonnenwind und das Magnetfeld im Sonnenwind hat eine solche Periode.
Aber noch eine andere und die zeigte sich dann als die entscheidende Wahl ist die Jupiterbahn auch zur Ekliptik etwas geneigt. Die Jupiter Rotations.
Achse, die ist nicht genau neunzig Grad, sondern etwas.
Dieter Erde ja auch nicht so, aber.
Dass der Äquator, der Jupit, der ist stark magnetisiert, also der hat ein starkes Magnetfeld,
deswegen dieser Äquator,
Ebenes aussieht wie eine auch so eine gewölbte Scheibe, die aber jetzt mit der Periode vom Jubital. Und Io, der umläuft, um den äh Jupiter,
hat dann so eine Konfiguration, dass da auch eine vierzehntährige Periode rauskommt von aus, wenn das von außen bracht dann ist Io.
Umlaufzeit weiß ich jetzt nicht genau.
Sieben Tage.
Sieben Tage ja äh und dann mit ähm Neigung der der Polarx kommt auch eine vierzehntägige Periode raus und zeigte sich, dass,
die Haupteffekte diese,
Magnetfeld ist. Und kleine nanometer große Staubteilchen die geladen sind,
die werden beschleunigt von dem Jubitel Magnetfeld jetzt in dem Fall hat man Magnetbeschleunigung,
und die treten dann im vierzehntägigen Rhythmus in einer Entfernung, werden die gesehen. Die sind natürlich dauernd, werden sie weggestreut, aber alle vierzehn Tage treffen sie einen bestimmten Punkt, nämlich die Holisse-Sonde.
Und das hat man,
schön wunderbares Seat, mein Kollege Harald Krüger, der dann das Experiment nach meiner Pension oder schon vorher übernommen hatte, äh konnte dann auch beim dritten Umlauf als wieder am Jupiter vorbei ging, äh konnte das wiedersehen.
Und mit Galola haben wir das im Jubiläums selber feststellt und da konnten wir dann auch die die genaue Dynamik dieser Teilchen äh feststellen.
Das war die eine Entdeckung. Äh die zweite Entdeckung war dann nach dem Jupiter vorbeifl.
Also Jupiter war ja da sozusagen nur so ein, so ein, so ein Bonus, ne? Weil man musste da halt vorbeifliegen für den Flyby, dass man überhaupt erstmal über die Sonne rüber kann, aber äh wenn man da halt schon vorbeifliegt, dann müsste man halt mal gleich mal mit.
Also diese Jubiter Stromteilchen, wie wir sie genannt haben, die vom IO herkommen, wie Bittermond ihr,
äh das war jetzt praktisch die erste völlig unerwartete Entdeckung.
Die zweite Entdeckung war dann nach dem Jubitär vorbeiflug, nachdem die Bahn dann nach Norden abgelenkt wurde und wieder ins innere Sonnensystem er.
Da haben wir eine Population von Staub entdeckt, die.
Nicht im Prokraden sind, um die Sonne läuft, sondern am Jupiter in dem Fall Retrogra,
pro Grad heißt die ganzen Planeten, bewegen sich im selben Sinn, um die Sonne, die Astorin, Planeten, das äh,
im selben Sinn, wie die Sonne sich auch dreht, das hat was mit der Entstehung der Planeten zu tun, die Scheibe da ist nicht wild durcheinander äh sondern hat sich formiert in einer Scheibe, die um die Sonne rotiert.
Und äh auch die Kometen, die Jupiter Family Kometen, insbesondere, die haben diese Umlaufrichtung, nur die Langperiodenkomedien haben andere.
Und deswegen als dann die Bahn nach Norden ging vom Juppte aus.
Kann man ähm sagen, wenn man zur Sonne blickt äh von äh Ulisus aus, kam die Drohkraden äh,
Planetaren, Teichen, die ihr eine Plantarequelle hatten von der linken Seite, aber wir sahen auch von der anderen Seite. Staub.
Die nicht planet haben Ursprung sein konnten. Von Kometen, Astriden oder sonst was.
Und das, den Staub, dieses Staubteilen konnten wir auch über den Polen der Sonne noch feststellen, also bei hohen Breiten, wo der.
Interplantagestauben schon kaum noch da war.
Selbst über den Polen war praktisch mit dem gleichen Fluss die äh ein Strom von Teilchen.
Das heißt im Sonnensystem ist es eigentlich genauso wie zu Hause, man halt einfach überall Staub.
Ja, aber die hat bestimmte Eigenschaften. Und hier haben wir jetzt plötzlich Staub gesehen, der ganz andere dynamische Eigenschaften hat, der aus einer anderen Richtung kam. Die.
Mit dem Planetensystem eigentlich nichts zu tun haben konnte. Und.
Ja und es gab eine weiter auch auf und das ist eine Beobachtung von äh neutralen äh.
Teilchen, Wasserstoff, Helium und so, das von einem Instrukt, die von einem Instrument, vom äh Rosenbauer aus Lindau.
Vom Max-Plancks ist für Eronomie damals hier heute Max Blanzet für Sonnensystemforschung in Göttingen äh gebaut worden war, dass solche Teils sind festgestellt habe. Und.
Äh die festgestellt haben, dass es ein Interstellermaterialstrom durch das Planetensystem gibt von.
Äh
Wasserstoff und Telium, Ionen, äh die das und unsere Staubteile, die wir gesehen haben, kamen aus derselben Richtung. Und das war als Interstellarisch äh haben wir das wir als Intersteller Staub,
identifiziert. Äh es gab noch andere Beobachtungen, wenn man mit ähm Ultraviolett äh Instrumenten,
gerade Wasserstoff, äh die Leimann Alpha Strahlung anguckt, dann sieht man, dass ähm.
Die aus einer besonderen Richtung im.
Intersteller im galaktischen Bezugssystem aus einer Richtung äh kommen und das ist eben der Hinterstaller Gas, was durch diese.
Sonnensystem fliegt. Und unser Staubteilchen, die wir gesehen haben, flogen aus der Kamm, aus der selben Richtung. Und damit hatten wir.
Dem starken Hinweis, dass das in der schnellere Teichen sind. Inzwischen wurden mit anderen Instrumenten Galileos auch Cassidi und äh.
Staubteilen bis zum Saturn dieser Strom von in der Staubteilchen gesehen. Und sogar mit Cassini, weil das kommen vielleicht noch drauf. Ähm dann sogar äh analysiert, grobchemisch analysiert.
Letzte Mal an dieser Stelle mal äh kurz diese diese Unterscheidung auch nochmal festhalten. Also Feldraumstaub ist klar,
wir reden einfach über kleinste Teilchen und mehr oder weniger sind sie halt überall. So diese Vorstellung von das Universum ist so ein pures Vakuum und da ist nix,
äh okay, da ist jetzt nicht viel und man läuft auch nicht die ganze Zeit in irgendwas rein, aber die Vorstellung, dass es sozusagen leer äh ist, also so richtig leer gesaugt,
Davon kann man sich glaube ich äh verabschieden. Es findet sich immer irgendwas, irgendwie, irgendwo. Kann man das so sagen.
Äh ja es gibt äh kaum Gebiete, wo man überhaupt keinen Staub findet.
Findet ja auch Joden und ja geladene Teichen.
Oder auch neutrale Teilchen praktisch auch überall, aber nur zum Teil mit sehr, sehr geringen Dichten, viel geringeren dichtmals hier auf der Erde.
Na klar, also ich sage auch nicht äh man muss die ganze Zeit husten, aber es ist sozusagen auch nicht nichts da. Und durch diese zahlreichen Missionen jetzt blicken wir ja,
wo sind wir jetzt? Äh Julisses war äh Anfang der neunziger Jahre,
Also wir blicken sozusagen so auf so fünfundzwanzig Jahre kontinuierliche Beobachtung durch verschiedene äh Missionen. Hat man einfach herausgestellt, okay,
man weiß in etwa wie viel Staub sich dort befindet, wo man hingeschaut hat, wie er beschaffen äh äh ist.
Noch nicht aber man noch nicht jedenfalls sehr gut, dass man dann wirklich das vergleichen könnte mit Analysen von Meteoriten oder sowas.
Okay, müssen sie vielleicht noch nicht im Bereich der kosmischen Chemie, aber wir sind sozusagen schon mal äh,
Es gibt eine Vorstellung davon, um welche Mengen es sich handelt und vor allem, darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen hinaus, wo kommt es her? Wo gehört es dazu? So und das war halt am Anfang eher so dieser,
ja, also der Interpletare Staub, also der quasi zwischen unserem Planeten, also Teil,
unseres Sonnensystems ist, wo sozusagen unser eigener Staub äh aus dem wir letztlich auch entstanden sind oder was davon noch übrig geblieben ist,
abgesehen von vielleicht äh hereingetragenen einzelnen äh Kometen, was noch eingefangen wurde, aber dieser Intastellare Staub, das ist sozusagen Staub, den man halt klar zuordnen könnte von,
jetzt so erstmal nichts unbedingt mit unserem Sonnensystem zu tun, sondern kommt von woanders.
Kann man das erstmal so äh festhalten, um diese Begriffe mal so ein bisschen klar zu bekommen.
Das ist genau richtig. Das ist eine ganz andere Kategorie. Allerdings.
Äh das ganze Sonnensystem vor vier,
viereinhalb Milliarden Jahren ist aus in der Stallarm, Staub und Gas hat es sich geformt. Also es wären so ganz.
Was anders ist das auch nicht und das war die nächste große Frage. Findet man noch Spuren in den Material von dem man hier das hier im Sonnensystem findet was,
Information über den Ursprung findest. Von Meteoriten konnte man das schon nachweisen und zwar man hat Isotope gefunden,
äh die ähm.
Hier auf der Erde innerhalb von viereinhalb Milliarden Jahren schon längst äh zerfallen wären und nicht mehr nachweisbar sind, hat man,
Reaktionsproduktion gefunden, die älter sind als äh viereinhalb Milliarden Jahre. Die also schon äh praktisch die Signatur von Interstellarem Material,
haben. Ungefähr der hundertstausendste Teil eines Meteoriten,
besteht noch aus ursprünglichem in der Stadt Lahmaterial, das nicht im Sonnensystem durch die protoplanetare Scheibe und Aufheizung der Sonne und Veränderung der Chemie sich verändert hat.
Kleinste Teilchen äh haben noch die Signatur von dem Ursprung. Also deswegen so ganz also es gibt eine ist eine weitere Verwandtschaft viel weiter als das zwischen.
Asteriden und Kommentaren, Staub oder Staub von Monden, der,
jetzt mit Cassini hat man den Enzelladus gefunden, den Eismond, der auch jetzt keine Vulkane, aber Gaizir hat, der besteht aus Eis und der stößt.
Wassertröpfchen aus, die aber noch Mineralien enthalten.
Müssen wir vielleicht erstmal was zu sagen, wie wieso ist der Mond Io zeigt der Vulkane,
Erdmondzeiten hat keine Vulkane, ist keine Aktivität mehr im Sinne, dass der äh Ehren sich groß verändert. Äh.
Denn der ist schon längst erkaltet seit aber der Jupiter Mond Io, der ist äh so weit so dicht am Jupiter dran.
Durchgeknetet.
Dass die Gezeitenreibung äh die äh Gezeiteneffekte das Material,
Sozialiten selber in Durchwalken wie sie sagen und dabei entsteht Hitze und Teil des Materials schmilzt und trinkt dann die Oberfläche und ekwandiert dann den Raum und bildet so Vulkane,
flüssiges Material und dadurch,
ähnlich wie es auf der Erde ist, äh verändert sich auch die Zusammensetzung. Bei der Erde ist im Zentrum,
Ein Eisenkern daraus darüber ist eine mehr silikatisches Material und an der Oberfläche ist eine ganz dünne Kruste von dem Material, was wir so um uns rum sehen und kennen
Äh das ist schon seit sehr frühen Zeiten äh so und die Erde ist immer noch geologisch aktiv und,
der äh Io durch die Gezeitenreitung, weil das Licht am Jubel da dran ist äh wird ähm.
Heute dauernd wird die äh wirkt eine zu einer Aufheizung.
Zum Vulkanismus hat. Ähnlich ist es bei dem Saturnmond in Zellados, der äh in der Entfernung von vier Saturnradien und den Saturn rumleicht, also als noch relativ dicht.
Übrigens, mein zweitlieblingsmondten.
Ja, ja, vor allem, weil der Aktivität zeigt Geisiere.
Die man direkt gesehen hat und durch die die Cassini Mission und mit unserem Staubinstrument da drauf durchgeflogen sind und unser Staubinstrument und das war eine andere große Entdeckung hat dann festgestellt, dass da nicht nur Wasser,
wie man's auch schon von der Oberfläche zieht, so Schnee,
sieht es aus wie eine beschneitete Landschaft, aber da waren Mineralen drin, sodass man schließen konnte, dass im Inneren.
Nicht bloß Wasser und Eis ist, sondern ein ein flüssiger See,
der in äh Kontakt mit einem äh mineralischen Kern,
des Mondes steht und dadurch aus aus dem Mineralien Salz auslöst, wie das auf der Erde passiert, ja. Die Flüsse tragen das Salz aus den Bergen in den Ozeanen, deswegen ist das mehr salzig,
und sowas passiert beim Entzeller des auf, nur das gibt's keine Flüsse, sondern es gibt Geisierer.
Jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen durch die Blume äh im Prinzip äh festgestellt, also wir reden ja von der Cassini Holgins äh Mission
Saturn System, auch da gibt's natürlich 'ne tolle Raumzeitfolge zu Nummer dreißig mit Michael Kahn, sehr spannender äh ähm sehr spannende Schildung der Mission, vor allem selber, wo ja auch so einiges äh schiefgegangen äh ist, also auf
letzten Metern dann noch ausgebügelt wurde. Ähm so und äh auf Cassini oder so auf Cassini war.
Heugens war ja die Sonder.
Nur die Sonne,
weiß ja nicht, ob die in der auch noch irgendwie Staub eingesammelt hat, aber nein, okay, gut, das ist äh klassisches Cassini, eine Mission, die ja mega lange gehalten hat, bis vor wenigen äh Jahren gelaufen ist, super erfolgreich, äh unglaublich äh eine der tollsten,
Mission finde ich äh überhaupt die so gelaufen sind. Äh gibt natürlich viele zur Auswahl, aber bin ich ein großer Fan von,
So und dort war dann auch ein neues Instrument an dessen Bau, sie beteiligt war, habe ich das richtig versteht, ne genau.
Vorgeschlagen hab und das sind PIs anfänglich war und das ist jetzt an meinen Kollegen später der dann mitgearbeitet hat schon weil mit dem Bau der Feststelle ist Ralf Ramer, der heute der Staubgruppenpleiter an der Universität in Stuttgart im Institut für Raum.
Was war denn da der technische Fortschritt so jetzt, wenn man jetzt über diese all diese Jahre äh gesehen haben, unterschiedliche äh Dinge konnten bestimmt werden bestimmte Dinge konnten nicht bestimmt werden. Wo befanden wir uns denn sozusagen zum Zeitpunkt von Cassin technisch.
Also äh wir hatten ja angefangen mit, dass zuerst schon am Anfang
praktisch alles machen wollt, aber das noch nicht so gut machen konnte. Also grad insbesondere die Zusammensetzung, die wurden dann mit den Jotto, den,
wesentlich verbessert. Allerdings die Kometen hatten dann Vorteil, dass da sehr viel Staub.
Im Interplantalen Raum, den wir mit Galileo und Ulusis auch in Planetaren Raum um äh Jupiter und auch im Erdbereich,
ist viel weniger. Staub da, deswegen mussten wir Instrumente groß bauen. Der große Erfolg von Galeo und Olisis Instrument war, die waren zehn Mal im Durchmesser,
in der Fläche der findlichen Fläche größer als der HEOS und Helios Instrumente.
Also die Heoselius hatten hundert Quadratzentimeter so. Ja und die,
Galeo und Lisses waren dann so äh ein Zehntel Quadratmeter große Flächen.
Recht eckig oder.
Und wie so ein Topf sahen die aus. Und ähm.
Oder einen Eimer, wenn sie wollen, äh das war die Einschlagsfläche und im Zentrum war dann der Ionen und Elektronendirektor, der dann den Einschlagsplasma die Signale aufgenommen hat. Und bei Cassini sollte ja eine.
Äh das Saturnsystem, wo zwar gesehen wurde, da gibt's die Ringe, durch die man nicht geflogen ist, weil das wird zu gefährlich, weil da große äh,
Körper drin sind bis,
Kilometer, aber auch die kleinen Zentimeter wären tödlich gewesen für Cassini. Aber im äußeren Bereich gibt's auch dort das auch selbst von der Erde, schon beobachtebar einen sehr dünnen Ring, den Ehring.
Und dem sollte das äh Cassini hauptsächlich die Messung Staubmessung machen und natürlich an den Satelliten und vom äh Planeten selber äh,
und dazu braucht man auch wieder diese großen tausend Quadratzimeer, Zehntel Quadratmeter Fläche,
aber wir wollten zusätzlich zu Gale und du lüstest dich bloß die Einschläge zuverlässig identifizieren soll, die sie vielleicht die Masse, die Richtung,
eine grobe äh Information über Geschwindigkeit sollte jetzt Kassidi auch noch die Teamszusammensetzung,
besser messen als im Methelius gemessen war. Nicht ganz so gut, wie sie was mit den,
und Vegas und helligen, aber doch so, dass man sinnvolle, chemische äh Informationen raushol.
Also, dass man konkret auch die Moleküle zum Beispiel bestimmen kann und nicht nur so, es könnte das, das oder das.
Massenauflösung von fünfzig gegenüber zehn, also bis fünfzig äh konnte man die einzelnen Massen auch trennen,
Und da drüber wurde es schwierig. Also da da sind ja so Haupt ähm bis zum Eisenhoch konnte man sie praktisch alle sehen. Magnesium, Silizium, Kohlenstoff.
Die wichtigen sozus.
Wichtigen, ja. Und da konnte man eben diese mineralischen Gehalt äh in den Eringteilchen die vollen Enzellabus ausgestoßen wurden. Äh nachweisen,
und dann im Saturn Entfernung auch die Intersteller und jetzt äh mit diesem Instrument identifizieren zunächst.
Und dann auch deren grobe Zusammensetzung äh bestimmen. Das war dann der Haupt.
Liefen die Instrumente auch bis zum Ende der Mission durch.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, das hat bei noch beim Eintauchen praktisch die letzten Daten wurden von unserem Staubinstrument äh äh Staub gesehen, der jetzt innerhalb der Hauptringe,
man von der Erde aus sieht nach äh feststellen konnte die praktisch auch wieder auch elektromognetische Weisen nach innen in die Atmosphäre hineingetrieben werden.
Ja.
Das war äh faktisch der Höhepunkt jetzt bisher, der Staubinstrumententwicklung.
Und auch halt sehr große wissenschaftliche Erfolge konnten Ehring sehr gut kategrophieren äh und auch identifizieren, dass der.
Der Hauptlieferant für diesen Staub ist. Während die anderen Monde, äh, die eben nicht so diese Zeiten, Anregungen unterworfen sind, eben nicht aktiv sind.
Jedenfalls nicht so wie ein Zelladus. Also das waren die äh.
Health Visionen im Interplanetaren und Planetarenbereich. Jetzt gab's da noch Rosetta, ähm das sollte vielleicht noch sagen, wenn wir noch Zeit haben.
Die Zeit haben wir auf jeden Fall. Rosetta war ja wie schon erwähnt ja auch schon mehrfach äh ein Thema.
Also das fing an gleich nach dem Mission Jotto.
Dass die Esa und NASA den nächsten Schritt äh identifiziert hat und äh die Esa hat,
an der Roger Boné, dass ähm Horizon two Sausen Programm der Esa entwickelt, das aus vier.
Cornerstore Mission, also Hauptmissionen äh bestehen sollte und davon eine implantarenbereich und die sollte eine.
Anfänglich eine Kometennukle Sambelmission sein, ein Mäden proben, Rückführmission,
Das geht natürlich viel weiter über den,
vorbeiflug, der bis dahin bei Helle gemacht wurde, hinaus. Äh das ging sogar noch einen Schritt weiter als den nächsten logischen Schritt, dass man erstmal in die Nähe eines Kometen fliegt und in der einen Kometen länger Zeit beobachtet,
das war, hatte die NASA vor in der sogenannten Comed Astroid Row Devo Mission Graf,
die eben zu Kometen, Astrid fliegen sollte und äh diesen Aspekt,
untersuchen soll. Das sollte zuerst passieren,
Daraufhin sollte diese Probenrückführermission der Esel gemeinsam mit Nase sein. Und da war ich auch beteiligt in der Studiengruppe, die,
überhaupt mal sagen, was will man denn wissenschaftlich da untersuchen und was, wie könnte man das tun wollen und was für Anforderungen hat es dann an die Mission.
Ähm und ähm.
Die ersten Ideen waren wirklich Abenteuerlich, da sollte sprach man von,
Ideen, dass man im Umlauf, Erdumlauf praktischen Space auf eine Space Station,
eine Raummission zusammenbaut, die man in einzelnen Teilen hochgebracht wird und daraus dann eine Rakete baut, die dann äh zum,
ähm einen Kometen äh fliegen soll und dann dort Proben nehmen sollte und dann zurückbringt,
Darüber haben wir diskutiert und das wurde ziemlich schnell klar, dass das nicht sehr praktikabel ist, denn bei einem der ersten Meetings sind da waren wir gerade im Kalteke,
und saß im Meeting oder kamen zum Meeting, gehörten nur in Nachrichten, dass der Challenger verunglückt.
Und das hat dann gleich.
Damit war klar, man kriegt nicht mehr genug Zeug hoch zur ISS. Ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt, habe ich noch gar nicht so drüber nachgedacht. Äh ist denn diese Idee überhaupt nochmal aufgegriffen worden
Mission von der ISS aus äh starten zu lassen, weil es ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen wie äh das Versprechen des Weltraumfahrstuhls ist. So, man kann halt,
größere Mission sich quasi oben zusammenbauen und würde sie dann irgendwie abstoßen und nochmal mit einer eigenen Rakete durchstarten lassen, hätte aber im Prinzip ja schon die Beschleunigung der ISS äh mit an Bord, was ja potenziell
die Reichweite vergrößern kann. Woran scheitert sowas?
Ja, also das war die erste eigentlich äh äh,
naheliegende äh Idee, äh dass man jetzt die äh ISS als Plattform nimmt, von dem aus jetzt weiter weggeht,
das zeigte sich aber sehr schnell, da die ISS eine bemannte Mission ist und die Anforderung an die Zuverlässigkeit, an die Sicherheit, dass ja nix passiert,
sind viel höher als bei unbemannten Missionen. Wenn's halt schief geht, dann hat man halt hundert Millionen verloren oder was immer die Mission kostet, aber es sind keine Menschenlebende.
Naja, okay und nicht gleich die.
Deswegen waren die Anforderungen der Papieraufwand, die Untersuchung, die Studien, die man machen muss, dass gar nichts passiert, viel höher und trieben die Kosten so hoch, dass das äh eine unbemannte Mission vom,
mit dem Shuttle hochbringen und von der ISS äh dann zu starten, von der ISS, insbesondere äh denn das hätte die ganze,
Möglichkeit verstanden, dass die ganze äh ISS damit beschädigt wird. Das hat das war das Ende.
Und da kam dann Ideen auf, dass man das so nicht machen sollte und es gab auch schon Ideen, wie man zu.
Kurz bei irischen Kometen, also Jupiter Familie, Kometen fliegen könnte, äh einen direkten Weg und dann äh die wieder zurückführen konnte. Äh,
Aal allerdings.
Äh damals waren die diese Grafmission, die Comed Radeprovision der NASA, die stand in Konkurrenz zu einer zu dem Vorläufer der Cassini-Mission.
Da sollten sogenannte Merinner Mark zwei Missionen werden, die auf einheitliches Raumfahrzeug auf das mal dahin fliegen sollen, zu dahin mit anderen Wissenschaftszielen.
Und das hat sich äh sehr schnell gezeigt, dass das zu teuer ist, wenn man einen Universalraumfahrzeug bauen wollte, was das alles kann,
Die Anforderung viel zu hoch und dann für die einzelnen Missionen werden Teile gar nicht benutzbar und dann hat man das aufgegeben. Und,
dann nun gesagt, man baut jetzt nicht ein Raumfahrzeug, das beides kann Kometen und Saturn äh,
sondern einzelne und dadurch äh war die einzelne Mission so teuer wie das einen Raumfahrzeug, was vielleicht beides können musste, wo man dann aber was nicht sehr sinnvoll war. Für die Entwicklung sehr viel teurer.
Und dann gab's Entscheidung Cassini zu machen und nicht diese Grafmission.
So, jetzt stand die Esa da mit ihrer Mission und wir mit unseren Studienthemen. Das war dann praktisch nicht mehr sinnvoll und möglich,
und auch mit hohem Risiko behaftet. Und sie wusste einige Zeit nicht, aber währenddessen während dieser Studienphase war dann zum Beispiel eine Frage bei der äh bei Flibermission, Proben einsammeln,
wie sieht denn das Zeug aus? Es gab ja noch keine Bodenproben, wie jetzt von Rosetta, dass man jetzt durchaus Informationen vom Kern hatte. Wusste es gar nicht. Und da kam dann die Idee auf, das könnte man im Labor simulieren.
Und es war gleichzeitig da der Dieter Stöffler aus Münster äh an die DFG einen Vorschlag gemacht, eine,
Expertelle Untersuchung zur Planetenentstehung zu machen und als Teilprojekt schlugen wir dann vor, eine Kometensumme bei der DLR in Köln zu machen. Die hatten doch die großen Weltraumsimulationskammern,
die so groß wie ein großes Zimmer war, in dem dann die Helios-Sonde getestet wurde,
einer Vakuumkammer mit Sonnenlicht beschienen wurde,
um zu sehen, dass die auch die Anforderung, die bei der Sonnenernährung da waren.
Die Stange rum und sollte abgerissen werden. Dann kamen wir auf die Idee, wenn er die schon abreißt, dann lasst uns vorher nochmal,
etwas machen, was ein Vakuumphysiker nie machen würde, nämlich Eis und Staub in eine Vakuumanlage reinzubringen, um zu sehen, was passiert, wenn der bestrahlt wird mit Sonnen, mit,
simulieren sollen.
Sozusagen nochmal so eine Abrissparty gefeiert.
So ungefähr, das war ein Projekt, das ging drei Jahre mit äh elf einzelnen äh Missionen, äh einzelnen,
ja Teilmission, wo zuerst mit einfachen da mussten wir erstmal haben wir inne eine Kammer gebaut, indem man Eis, was man,
Zuerst erzeugt durch Brühen von Wasser in flüssigen Stickstoff und Beigabe von Staub oder eine Schlammmischung, wenn sie wollen,
in ins ins flüssige Stichstoff ein, dann gab das so eine Art Schnee, der schmutzig war.
Und den hatten wir dann in die Kammer gepackt, in einen Behälter, der gekühlt war auch mit Fischenstickstoff und Vakuumkammer eingebaut,
und dann Instrumente drum rum, das waren Kameras,
selber wie ein Weltrauminstrumente abgeschirmt waren und wirklich kleine Staubdirektoren, Staubsammler äh Lasermethoden, um,
die Gas und Staubemission zu untersuchen, das alles in die Kammer eingebaut und dann bestrahlt und das ging dann meistens eine Woche lang
äh Tag und Nacht wollte guckt, dass äh was tut sich da und da gab's elf verschiedene äh ähm,
Einzelexperimente, die von einem internationalen Team, also wir waren da, da waren Amerikaner dabei, da waren Engländer, Franzosen, Italiener,
äh äh Israelis ähm äh.
Du Schande äh aus der russischen Föderation ähm Leute, die alle da dran sind, die mit Instrumenten und mit Kenntnissen da mitgewirkt haben, haben wir also ungefähr fünfzig Leute bei alliertem solchen Experiment,
vorbereitet war, haben wir die zu in dreieinhalb Jahren durchgeführt und erstmalig,
insbesondere vom DLR wurde versucht, dann auch Proben zu nehmen, also ein Bohrer entwickelt, der da reingehen sollte in das Material und das Material rausnehmen sollte, äh wie, wie müsste er beschaffen sein? Und wie verändert sich diese,
Schneeprobe, wenn sie wollen, im durch die Bestrahlung. Das waren ganz interessante Sachen, äh die man jetzt dann benutzen konnte bei der Analyse der Rosetta Daten,
die gezeigt haben, dass dieser lockere Schnee dann sich verfestigt. Der Rekristalisiert.
Das Wasser, was dann aus dem Eis,
abdampft, äh geht ja nicht nur nach außen weg, sondern auch durch die Poren ins Innere und durch die äh tiefe Temperatur kristallisiert ist, gefriert es wieder und verbinde das prak,
so dass dann nach einiger Bestrahlung war das ein ganz fester Brocken nur an der Oberfläche wurde dann praktisch das,
Eis und Staub abgedmpft, aber im Inneren hat taten auch Veränderungen auf. Und genau das hat man mit Rosetta auch gesehen. Jetzt ist das am Kometensee auf der wieder extrem fest zu Teil,
Nur an der Oberfläche war so eine Staubschicht drauf.
Ja.
Das war ja so ein bisschen diese Idee des schutzigen Schneeballs. Äh das war ja so ein bisschen so die Sicht äh äh auf äh Kometen. Ich äh habe so den Eindruck Rosetta dieses Bild etwas ähm einer Variation äh zu führt. Also
weiß nicht, ob das Bild noch so.
Ja, nee, also Schneeball ist es sicher dicht, das war die Ausgangshypothese von Fred Wippe, ein der,
großen Vordenke für von Kometen, aber auch vom Staub in der Plantanstaub, der war so praktisch der Grendmaster auch schon zu meiner Zeit und er war auch dann,
äh Staubkonferenz neunzehnhundertfünfundsiebzig hier in Heidelberg, die wir durchgeführt haben. Also der hat dieses äh Bild,
geformt, was ich in Teilen äh bewahrheite habe. Allerdings die mechanischen Eigenherrschaften,
waren doch ganz andere, weil eben das Material selbst im Kometen, der sehr kalt ist, äh, sich verändert. Durch die Bestrahlung von außen und.
Na ja, die Aussetzen der die Kometen sind ja auch mit den Planeten vor viereinhalb Millionen Jahren entstanden nur sehr weit weg, sodass selbst das,
Wasser noch äh nicht einfach gasförmig wird, so wie im inneren Sonntag. Deswegen die Ideren,
innerhalb von Jupiter die Asteroiden und die Terression Planeten Merkel äh Venus Erde Maas. Er besteht am wesentlichen aus Gestein,
weil da draußen die Gasrisse sind, die noch äh die volatileren Elemente noch enthalten und die Kometen sowieso sogar noch in gefrorener Form. In Eis und auch die Wunde da draußen beim Saturn sind halt Eismonde.
Also deswegen ähm diese Kometen, die von da draußen waren.
Die sollten am ursprünglichsten noch die Eigenschaften des Materials enthalten, wie sie beim Entstehen des Planetens.
Aber das hat sich dann gezeigt durch Prozesse.
Strahlung durch die Sonne, wenn sie ins innere Sonnensystem kommen, aber durch die milliardenlange Bestrahlung mit Kosmetikstrahlen verändern sich die Oberflächen auch äh äh ziemlich stark.
Also die sind auch schon Veränderungen äh unterworfen und ähm deswegen sind die auch nicht mehr so.
Pristine nennt man es ursprünglich, wie man das anfänglich gedacht hat. Zumindest an der Oberfläche, deswegen wollte man mindestens so einen Meter tief reinkommen, einen Kometen, das ist,
jetzt wollte man bei der komierten Probenrückführung um möglichst originales Prästines ursprüngliches Material äh zu finden.
Deswegen wollte man ja auch reinbohren in den äh äh in den Kometen. Das äh hat ja leider nicht so funktioniert, wie man sich das so erhofft hat.
Aber die Vorarbeiten dazu haben wir in dieser Kometensimulation Cosi äh äh gemacht und die Leute,
Spuren und die DLR-Leute, die da dran beteiligt sind,
die äh waren speziell an den Proben, die in die Tiefe gehen, die Temperaturprofil messen und sowas, die Bohrer, die dort gebaut wurden ähm kamen aus dieser,
Kometensimulationsgruppe, die die praktisch dann Vorbereitung war,
war ursprünglich für was anderes, nämlich Probenrück für, aber dann war das auch sehr nützlich dann für die viele Sonder äh die er dann vom ähm,
Rosenbauer und äh Feuerbacher Rosenbauer vom MPF Aeronie und.
Vom DLR Einzelpferden, Simulation äh vorangetrieben wurde.
Auch dazu habe ich natürlich eine Raumzeit äh Folge im Angebot. Wie sollte es anders sein, Rumzeit achtundfünfzig, da habe ich mir Stefan Ullamitz äh geschnappt und dann nochmal nach
dem alles gelaufen war nochmal so ein bisschen zusammengefasst was denn am Ende dann doch noch bei herausgekommen ist das ist ja so einiges. Die Mission war ja an sich super erfolgreich,
glaube ich äh letztlich sehr viel mehr
erreicht, als man äh hätte sich so vorstellen können. Und vor allem, er findet das jetzt ganz interessant, weil wir sind ja jetzt im Prinzip so mit diesem Weltraumstaub äh gestartet, erstmal so als
Ist das ein Hindernis? Also haben wir erstmal eine rein mechanische Betrachtung in gewisser Hinsicht, dann geht man in zunehmenden Maße äh äh hin, sich eben der Zusammensetzung der Analyse bis hin der Chemie äh äh so anzunähern über verschiedene Missionen, hat sehr unterschiedliche Bereiche
des Sonnensystems abgeklappert, um da irgendwie das Ganze noch in Bezug zu nehmen und,
im Prinzip steckt ja immer so ein bisschen die Frage dahinter, so, okay, was ist eigentlich so das Urmaterial? Wie äh war eigentlich das,
Material beschaffen aus dem unser Sonnensystem
vor allem natürlich die Planeten, aber auch die Sonne, sich eben äh zusammengesetzt haben und wo kann man sie eigentlich finden? Jetzt ist ja der Staub, der eben so herumfliegt im All.
Auch permanent dieser kosmischen Strahlung ausgesetzt und wahrscheinlich kann man da aus dem genauso wenig herauslesen, wie eben aus dieser Oberfläche der Kometen, aber so in den Kommeten und in die Astroiden hineinzugehen, das wäre dann sozusagen eigentlich der nächste
äh Schritt und die nächste Konsequenz.
Das ist zwar als Ziel ausgegeben, aber es gibt bisher noch keine konkrete äh Planung, konkrete Mission, Studien dazu gibt es, aber noch keine Mission leider, die,
äh
dieses Ziel jetzt direkt äh als Ziel hat. Aber die Vorarbeiten äh sind gemacht und ich glaube man könnte, wenn dann äh also es wird eine aufwendige Mission. Das heißt teuer.
Ja gut, aber äh Heiabus hat zwei äh von Japanern mit dem Messgott Linder vom DLR, die haben ja eine Probe genommen, die ist ja sozusagen auf dem Rückweg, ne?
Ja ja, Probenrückführung gab's jetzt schon einige,
auch von Kometen, die Startups Mission hat ja durch Vorbeiflug am Komäden in der Koma, also in dem,
Reif, wo der Staub, der vom Committen wegfliegt, er proben äh aufgenommen hat und die zur Erde zurückgeführt hat und dann auch schon außerordentlich,
interessante und auch überraschende Ergebnisse gebracht, dass man dort ähm Materialien findet, wie wir sie von mehr Theoriten her kennen, die ja in so näher,
entstanden sind, zumindest in der jetzigen Form, wie man sieht und von denen man glaubt, dass ein Teil dieser.
Körner, die da drin sind, Mineralien ähm äh.
Calcium, Aluminiumreiche, Einschlüsse zum Beispiel, äh die nur entstanden äh sein können bei sehr hohen Temperaturen, wie es in der Nähe der Sonne herrschen. Äh solche Körner hat man in den,
unter den Körnern, die man von äh dem äh Startust-Kometen Wild zwei ähm.
Zurückgebracht hat gefunden. Also das war schon überraschend, das führt dann dazu, dass äh die Ideen, dass das die Protoplanetare,
Wolke, die um die Sonne sich bildete, in der aus der sie dann die Planeten sich.
Die eigentlich sehr gut durchmischt gewesen sein soll, dass ein Teil von dem Material, was ganz dicht an der Sonne.
Sich gebildet hat, kondensiert ist und verändert hat, bis nach außen gebracht wurde, zu wo die Kometen waren. Natürlich nur zum kleinen Teil, aber doch immerhin, dass selbst die Parkhana, die bei,
mit Startups zurückgebracht hat schon solche äh kann enthalten, also das zeigt, dass die Ideen dann,
der ähm Planetenentstehung ähm modifiziert werden mussten,
insbesondere was die chemische Durchmischung äh der Planeten.
An welchen Missionen mangelt es ihnen jetzt? Also was sind sozusagen die Missionen, die es noch hier noch nicht gibt, die es aber eigentlich geben müsste.
Na ja, also äh ich habe hier angefangen, das war auch mein beim äh Profikarriereinstrumenten zu entwickeln. Zuerst mal zuverlässige Instrumente und dann Instrumente, die immer,
äh mehr leistungsstärker wurden, mehr äh konnten. Und da hat sich.
In den so ab zweitausend insbesondere mit Cassini äh eine neue Idee gegeben.
Nämlich Cassidi konnte auf dem Weg zum Saturn erstmalig zuverlässig.
Äh das Staubteils, die elektrische Ladung, die das Staubteilchen tragen äh messen.
Und zwar Staubteil, den Weltraum äh sind, die sind dem Sonnenwindplasma ausgesetzt, das besteht aus Jon und Elektronen,
und es werden von der Sonne bestrahlt und es werden entstehen Sekundärelektronen, die weggehen. Das Plasma, da die.
Fluss der Elektronen höher ist als der Hund, weil die kleiner sind, schneller sind ist höher, die würde Plasma würde negativ aufladen, der Sonnenwind, der Elektronen auslöst, die weggehen, ist positiv aufladen.
Äh und was wir direkt zeigen konnten im Weltraum, äh dass die Staubteicht eben.
Interplantan Raum äh positiv geladen sind. Das war auch vermutet worden aus Abschätzungen, wie.
Wie hoch diese verschiedenen Flüsse sind, aber es niemals nachgewiesen, obwohl wir schon mit Helios immer versucht hatten, das zu messen, aber die Störungen waren so groß, dass wir das nicht zuverlässig war und.
Das heißt, sie stehen im Wesentlichen unter dem Einfluss des Sonnenwindes, kann man das daraus folgen.
Im Wesentlichen unein dieses Fotoeffekt des Lohn UV.
Diese die laden die Teilchen im Interplantail positiv aus. In den Magnetosphären um diese äh großen Planeten im Jupiter System und im Saturnsystem,
besonders in den das Plasma so dicht ist in der Manosphäre,
da überwiegt die Negative Aufladung und das hat man am Saturn sehr schön sehen. Man konnte Profile der Ladungen in der manuffäre feststellen im Ehing,
weiter draußen, draußen waren sie positiv wie im Interplantaram, aber drin, wo das Plasma so stark war, waren sie negativ aufgeladen.
Und das ergab die Möglichkeit, diese Ladungsfeststellung, dass man bevor das Teilchen einschlägt.
Schon Information hat, genaue Informationen über die Geschwindigkeit,
also man hat dann Gitter vorne beim Eintritt von dem Detektor, wo ich durchfliege, an dem man die Ladung misst und dann in Koinsidenz mit den Einschlagssignalen.
Aha, da war paar Mikrosekunden vorher schon ein Signal da. Und dadurch kann man die Geschwindigk.
Und da kamen wir auf die Idee, äh nicht nur.
Die Geschwindigkeit zu messen, sondern auch die Richtung, indem man jetzt nicht nur ein ganzes Gitter nimmt, sondern einzelne drehte.
Und dann je nachdem wo und zwar in verschiedenen Ebenen, die senkrecht zueinander sind, die drehte.
In verschiedenen Richtungen, äh die Position.
Das Staubtor ist es bestimmt. Und mit der Positionsbestimmung gibt's sofort eine Möglichkeit die Dreiecktore hier zu bestimmen, indem man zwei solche Ebenen hat, XY eben,
hintereinander und einen gewissen Abstand kann man genau sagen, da ist in der ersten Ebene durchklungen und hier an der zweiten und in die vier Richtung.
Mhm. Man triaguliert das sozusagen und dann äh weiß man genau, wo es herkommt.
Noch nicht. Man kriegt die Dreijektor hier raus.
Aber die wird natürlich verändert durch das Gravitationsfeld der Sonne, durch das Magnetfeld des Sonnenwindes und als muss berücksichtigt werden. Aber man kriegt in Hinweise auf die.
Auf die äh.
Der Teilchen auf den Einschlag, das wird direkt gemessen und dann kriegt man Hinweise auf die Bahn, auf den sie finden und damit kriegt man Hinweise auf die ursprüngliche Teilchen.
Das wurde jetzt bei Kassi schon gemacht oder das.
Da hat man Cassini, hat man überhaupt erst gesehen, dass man das techn.
Die Ladung messen kann.
Man die Ladung messen kann, man kann die Geschwindigkeit bestimmen. Das war ein einfaches Gitter, das war noch nicht diese.
Und wenn man so ein Doppelgitter äh in ein Instrument machen würde, hätte man diese Information auch zusätzlich.
Heute ist äh hat sich daraus Idee Staubastronomie zu machen, dass man als Staubteleskop.
Beim richtigen optischen Teleskops sieht man vor Tonen von einer gewissen Richtung kommen,
und man misst die Eigenschaften, die das Spektrum der Foton, die Energie der Foton und kriegt damit Information aus dem äh was dort, aus dem nicht emittierenden Objekt,
was da passiert. Und hier jetzt mit Staubastromie ähm.
Mit einem sogenannten Staubteleskop, was am vorderen Teil aus einem Dreiektoriensensor besteht und hinten ein Einschlagsspektrumeter, was die Zusammensetzung misst, kriegt man Richtung,
und die Materialeigenschaften äh des Staubzeichens. Das ist Staubastronomie.
Das heißt, man könnte wie groß würde man sowas bauen wollen, wenn man jetzt äh freie Wahl hätte.
Das sind solche, das sind solche Größen, die.
Ersten befinden sich direkt im Vorbereitung zum Flug. Ähm, das sind so große Instrumente wie Cassini, also Cassini war ja schon ein ganz schöner Klapper,
Instrument achtzig Zentimeter hoch, vierzig Zentimeter Durchmesser, so ein Topf,
ähm dem das Ganze untergebracht war. Noch auf dem Drehtisch, weil das ja dann in bestimmte Richtungen das misst ja nicht aus allen Richtungen, sondern.
Zeigt immer irgendwo hin.
Als solche Staubteleskope befinden sich in der Entwicklung. Das eine in USA,
von Kollegen, von zuerst bei Casini mitgearbeitet, dem Sascha Kämpf aus, der jetzt in der Staubgruppe von Miha Orani in Bolder ist ähm für die Europa-Clipper-Mission.
Das ist 'ne Mission der NASA zum Jupiter Mond Europa.
Von dem man annimmt, dass der auch aktiv ist. Das ist ja der Mond, der von Eis bedeckt ist, aber offensichtlich an dem noch,
Eis, das Eis zum Teil im Inneren vermutet man geschmolzen ist, dass es unter der Eisdecke Ozean gibt,
und die Idee ist, dass sich dort dann.
Lebensformen entwickelt haben könnte. Und äh das ist ganz spannend, äh da eins der Ziele ist sogar die ähm.
Dieses biologische Material ähm dass man,
äh dort äh messen könnte, wenn's den's gibt, sowohl optisch spektroskopisch, also Infrarot, äh, spektoskopisch.
Oder mit einem und mit Staubteleskop zu müssen. Das ist dieses Staubteilskopf, was für die Europa-Klippermission vorbereitet wird.
Service Dust Maß Analyzer, ist das dann wahrscheinlich? Suda. Mhm.
Und es gibt ein äh für die Destiny Plus Mission, das ist eine japanisch deutsche Projekt.
Wo die Japaner, dieses Raumfahrzeug und den Staat waren und wir das Hauptinstrument nämlich ein Staubteleskop.
Äh entwickelt. Diese Destiny Plus ist für die für die Japaner im Prinzip so eine,
ja eine der ersten Mission um die Fähigkeiten der Japaner zu Interplantage zielte Plantage Mission zu machen die soll zum Asteriden Feton gehen.
Fehlton ist der Ursprungsastorid.
Der Gemeiniden, das Gemeniden Motorschauers und da möchte man den Staub messen,
in Nähe von Feton,
Also, dass man in Gemeniden sitzt, sind Teilchen so im Zentimeter Größe, vielleicht runter bis hundert Mikrometer, also Zehntelzentimeter Größe, noch.
Hadermethoden da möchte man die.
Zusammensetzen des Staubes äh messen und auf dem Weg dahin und hinterher an der Dach dem Vorbeiflug am Feton äh möchte man Interplanetaren,
Intersteller, Staub, chemisch untersuchen.
Durch das Traktorensensor äh kann man diese Teilchen unterscheiden. Ja aufgrund der Bahnen oder Traktoren, die die Teilchen haben, die dann gemessen werden sollen und die.
Durch die Chemie soll man eben Informationen aus über das Material herauskriegen. Das sind prak.
Jetzigen, modernen Instrumente der Staubastronomie. Stop-Telesk.
Also die jetzt auch wirklich konkret geplant sind.
Konkret geplant.
Ob ich das so richtig raushöre, am allerliebsten wäre ich wahrscheinlich so ein dediziertes äh
Staubteeloskop, was man, was weiß ich, an äh Lagrange Punkt zwei äh festnagelt und äh so in die Welt äh reinhorcht, ein paar Jahre einfach die ganze Zeit die Staubpartikel aufnimmt und,
eben versucht herauszufinden, wo jetzt gerade äh was hergeflogen kommt.
Na gut, das ist die Destinemission, tut sowas ähnliches. Sie ist zwar nicht an einem Punkt im Raum äh.
Festgebracht, sondern die fliegt auf einer Bahn ungefähr eine astronomische Einheit, also Erdams statt um die Sonne und macht dann dort, dass dann, dass es saubt, den's dann,
ähm äh der den der auf dieses Instrument auftrifft den analysiert,
die Ursprung, die Bahnen äh,
identifiziert und dann auch äh Informationen über die Zusammensetzung liefert. Also das ist schon so ein eine fast Idealmusion. Ich hätte es gerne noch und das haben wir,
vorgeschlagen, als es der Esa, als drum ging, eine der nächsten großen Missionen, DL zwei Mission,
zu definieren haben wir eine Mission vorgeschlagen die jetzt,
gleichzeitig ein Infrarot-Teleskop trägt.
Denn Infrarot Messung sind komplementär zu unseren Institutionmessungen. Infrarot ist besonders sensitiv auf Staub,
äh die messen Objekte, die bei äh hundert Kellen, also äh,
noch können Objekte festgestellt werden, staub äh Teilchen und so hat man ja mit den ersten Teleskopen, Iras zum Beispiel diese Commit Trails gefunden,
von Teilchen äh in der,
im interplantanen Raum, die so praktisch die Vorläufer der Meteorströme sind, die man dann, wenn sie dann die Erde da durchliegt als Meteorstrom sich zeigt.
Wo dann die schönen Sternschnuppentage äh anstehen.
Genau, aber da hat man, da, da sieht man halt nur die, die.
Wirklich jetzt kollidieren, aber so kann man mit Infrarot kann man sozusagen sehen, so hier hier ist ein Komet vorbeigeflogen. Den sieht man zwar als solchen nicht mehr, aber man sieht halt diesen Trail, weil er eben eine leichte Erwärmung quasi aufweist durch diesen Staub, den er zurückgelassen hat.
Genau, genau und äh warum wollen wir das oberhalb der Ekliptik machen? Weil bisher sitzt man in der Ekleptik, in dem zentralen Bereich der Sodiakalwolke, Staubwolke als Linse vorstellen,
zur Ehre zur Egliptik abgeplagtet ist, weil die ganzen Quellen,
Im Wesentlichen die Kurzperioden Kometen halten eine starke Konzentration zu ergibt. Ja. Von oben könnte man draufgucken und praktischen dreidimensionales Bild mit dem Infrarot,
messen und durch die Bahn dann, die dann immer wieder durchgeht mit dem Teleskop jetzt auch noch chemische Informationen zu haben.
Wie lange äh kann man so einen Kometen Trail nachdem ein Komet vorbeigeflogen ist, vermutlich über Infrarot noch detektieren? Reden wir von Tagen, Wochen, Monaten, Jahren.
Ach so, ja, also ein Umlauf zunächst mal von den Kurzperioden, es ist so in der Größenordnung von äh sechs, sieben Jahren. Das ist einmal rum.
Nee, nicht wie lange der Umlauf braucht, sondern wenn jetzt der Komit irgendwo vorbeigeflogen ist und ich schaue mir diesen Trail an.
Also wir haben, wir haben.
Lange kann ich den wahrnehmen.
Äh Simulationen von dem Trail, der zu ihm auf der Simenko hinterlässt, äh, gemacht und dann sieht man,
das,
der sich erstmal entlang der Bahn, also zuerst mal am Kometen, aber dann verteilen die äh teilstensweise unterschiedliche Umlaufzeiten haben entlang der Bahn.
Und äh da,
kurz vor Jürgen haben wir eben alle in der Nähe des Jupiters vorbeigehen, denn der hat die mal wahrscheinlich auf diese Bahn gebracht,
dir, der natürlich aus Istanbul. Und da äh werden die Teilchen am Video wieder gestreut und praktisch in den Hintergrund,
Interplantanstabs reingestreut und das zu braucht es hunderte tausende von Jahren,
Man glaubt, dass Alter einiger Meteor-Ströbe ist so zehntausend im Extremfall fest, leicht hunderttausend Jahre, wo die Teilchen ausgestoßen wurden.
Aber wenn ihr es einfach so ein Komet so äh an der Erde äh vorbeifliegen würde,
zu weit weg, so und dann ist aber auch schon wieder aus dem Blick heraus. Wie lange könnte man, wenn man jetzt mit Infrarotteleskop auf die Bahn schaut, die er genommen hat,
an dem hinterlassenen Staub wirklich noch ein Signal, ein Wärmesignal feststellen, wie, wie lange würde das halten.
Also der zehntausend Jahre würde ich sofort sagen, das haben die Simulationen. Ja, ja, ja. Äh na ja, es da sich auf der ganzen Bahn dann verteilen.
Das ist der Prozess, dass sie einfach unterschiedliche Anfangsgeschwindigkeiten haben. Fliegen sie auf leicht anderen Bahnen, die einander Umschlaufgeschwindigkeiten haben, als der Körper selber und deswegen,
verteilen sich. So und von den, wenn der Jupiter dann äh streut immer was raus.
Dass es dann äh kleinste Mengen und äh da die Umlaufbahnverhältnis ähm.
Ja, dass das alle zehn,
Jahre vielleicht zwanzig Jahre passiert soll für ein bestimmtes Staubzeichen, dass es mal da in der Nähe ist äh am Jupiter und ist die Abschwächung sehr gering und deswegen glaube ich, dass so äh,
zehntausend Jahre, wir haben da einen sehr schönen Film gemacht von den äh Strom von Sherio Move Gersemenco, wie der sich im Laufe der Zeit äh verändert. Das ist ganz spannend. Es gibt's im Internet.
Aber ich meine, wenn die so eine kurze Umlaufzeit haben und sie bahnen sich so lange nachweisen lässt,
dann heißt es ja, dass das Ding eigentlich so eine ewige Bremsspur äh hinterlässt, also dass man das eigentlich der Weg, den die äh Kometen äh konkret äh nehmen,
permanent markiert ist, also man muss den Kobeten eigentlich gar nicht sehen. Man könnte ja mit Infrarotstrahlung äh Detektoren einfach draufschauen, würde sozusagen die vollständige Bahn wahrnehmen oder zumindest den Teil, wo man hinschaut, ist das so.
Das ist so und das wäre nämlich dann besonders schön, wenn man das von oberhalb oder unterhalb der Ekliptik machen könnte, dann ist man nicht in dem dichten Teil. Also im Nebel sieht man ja auch nur Sachen, die sehr dicht bei einem sind,
sondern man sieht praktisch die ganze Wolke und dann kann dort drin die einzelnen Trails äh.
Also man hat natürlich dann immer noch den Rest der Milchstraße, der natürlich auch noch Infrarote Signale macht, das muss man ja davon auch irgendwie noch trennen können.
Ja natürlich der allerdings das Hauptinteresse wird von den galaktischen Infrarotastronomen kommen, die wollen nach draußen gucken,
sind natürlich, dass es zur DK-Licht erhindert, deswegen den Vorteil hätte eine solche Bahn ebenfalls, dass man nach in das eigene System guckt, aber dann nach außen auch.
Gestern.
Ja. Also das ist so der große Traum eine solche Mission äh zu machen.
Vielleicht mal so zum Abschluss nochmal so eine generelle Frage, was vermuten sie denn, was so.
Was wir noch aus dem Staub noch so alles herausgelesen bekommen werden. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, das steht eigentlich noch so gefühlt so ein bisschen alles am am Anfang.
Absolut, absolut. Wir stehen seit, also meine Forschung, die ich selber miterlebt habe, stand fünfzig Jahre am Anfang.
Mhm.
Aber hat sich weiterentwickelt. Also die Staubastronomie.
Äh hat glaube ich eine große Zukunft. Aber mein Teil daran ist erstmal abgeschlossen. Ich kann dazu nichts mehr beitragen, nur mit Wunderung sehen, was die Kollegen tun.
Ja, aber ist natürlich nochmal ein interessanter äh äh Vektor, weil man ja nun ohnehin von dieser äh multiplen Wahrnehmung des äh
Universums äh fiel, da ja sehr viel passiert ist. Die Gravitationswellen sind
äh dazu gekommen. Man kann über Neutrinos auf einmal einen komplett neuen Blick machen. Also so diese Dominanz des Elektromagnetismus ist so ein bisschen äh vorbei und wenn man jetzt sozusagen über die Partikel selber auch noch in gewisser Hinsicht eine eine Information bekommen könnte, mit der man sicherlich nicht so weit in die Vergangenheit schauen kann. Aber zumindest auch den Ist.
Äh äh Zustand mal auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise wahrnehmen kann. Das ist ja so wie wie Meeresströmung in gewisser Hinsicht. Da äh die man dann daraus herauslesen kann.
Das ist absolut richtig. Äh man muss sich vor Augen halten äh den Interplanetarstaub, so wie er,
so wie wir ihn sehen, der ist nicht seit Anfang des Planetensystems da,
sondern die Staubteißen werden. Ich habe jetzt schon einen Effekt benannt, die Streuung an den Planeten, die Bahnen verändern sich äh laufen, Teil wird rausgestreut, verschwindet für immerhin in der Stellerenraum,
teilt, weiter zur Sonne und bisschen schließlich in der Sonne landet und äh supplemiertem Sonnenwind rausgetragen wird, also die Moleküle und Atome,
Ähm,
Beim Interstadan ist auch äh ja, ach so und aus den Untersuchungen der Mondgrade, wo wir den Fluss bestimmt haben, äh konnten wir die Lebensdauer von Interplanetalen Staubteil aufgrund von,
Zusammenstößen bestimmen. Und da haben wir gemerkt.
Dass die kleinsten Teichen, die werden durch den sogenannten Pointing Robotson zur Sonne getrieben. Der Strahlungsdruck durch durch die Strahlung der Sonne auf die Teichen wirkt,
der wird nicht nur eine als Abschwächung, der gravitativen Anziehung in die Sonne, sondern er wird gleichzeitig dient äh führt zu einer Abbremsung der Stellen und Bahn,
Spiralen langsam zur Sonne hin, der sogenannte Pointing Robotsoneffek.
Der andere konkurrierende Effekt und der aufwirksame Effekt sind die Zusammenstöße, die stoßt und dann werden wir zusammen und da wird den Fluss ziemlich gut abschätzen können, könnten wir die Lebensdauer feststellen. Die Staubteilchen.
Die wir so sehen, die haben höchstens also bis zu Millimetergröße haben höchstens.
Zehntausend bis hunderttausend Jahre Lebensdauer. Dann sind sie weg.
Zerkleinert und die kleine Hand noch kürzere Lebenssache, also das Material ist weg.
Einfach entweder in der stillem Raum getrieben oder in der Sonne äh verdampft. Äh.
Weiter draußen natürlich hat, ist die Lebensdauer länger, weil der Pony bei uns länger braucht, eine Dichte ist geringer, deswegen sieht Lebensdauer auch länger,
aber der Intelsteller Staub. Von dem glaubt man, dass der Lebenslauf von hundert Millionen Jahren hat, weil dies so geringe Dichte hat,
äh und die Zerstörungsprozesse sind.
Entsprechend langsamer, ja.
Andere. Deswegen damit kann man zurückblicken in viel längere Zeit und was man und da ist jetzt die große Frage beim Interständern Staub.
Ist das ursprünglicher Sternenstaub.
Der von Kohlestoff streichen oder äh sauerstoffreichen ähm Sternen kommt, je nach Größe und Alter ähm,
gibt's da, die im Endstadium an der Oberfläche in ihren Sternhüllen,
bis zum Kohlenstoff ist die Verbrennung gelangt und die ist an der Oberfläche abgestoßen so praktisch Rußwolken. Ruß sind kleine Staubteiche,
in der in der Stelle einen Raum äh geben,
Und die anderen, die sauerstoffreichen, äh die geben äh mineralischen Staub, Silikate und sowas und,
und und Super Nova eisenreiche äh Staubabweit super Nova entsteht, wenn das Hauptmaterial verbrannt ist und dann äh bis zum Eisen aus Wasserstoff und Helium sich.
Hohe Elemente bis zum Eisen und bei den Explosionen dann noch höhere Elemente gebildet haben, die dann in der Stelle am Raum ausgegeben. Findet man solchen ursprünglichen Sternenstaub.
Der dann wie ich schon sagte, eine chemische und isotopische Situatur zeigen sollte oder findet man den Staub, der dann.
Danach in in molekularen und äh Wolken eingefangen wurde und sich dort abgekühlt hat und Teil dieser Molkar Molekülwolken,
äh hat einen Anteil von ungefähr einem Prozent in Masse, an Staub.
Und dabei treten Veränderungen. Die Staubteichen weiß da so kalt ist in den äh Molekülwolken, kann sich zusammenballen und äh können sich dann durch Feststoffreaktionen neue äh Verbindungen bilden,
und er kann sich verändern und es kann eine Durchmischung geben, die verschiedenen Sternstaubtypen, die ich jetzt schon genannt habe, können sich vermischen und.
Eine Mischung von allem in was im Prinzip dann.
Unser Sonnensystem kann man nicht sagen, das ist alles aus dem Kohlstoff haltigen,
Staub von einem Kohlenstoffstern entstand oder anderen, sondern ist 'ne Mischung von allem. Ist diese Durchmischung erst im Sonnensystem passiert?
Als es dann zusammen kam, in der Nähe der Sonne aufgeheizt wurde, wieder supplemiert ist und andere Mineralien gebildet hat.
Oder hat sich das vor.
Vorher in dem Wolken. Und das ist jetzt die spannende Frage beim interstadieren Staub, die wir noch nicht beantworten können, aber dann hoffentlich mit den Staubteleskopen in absehbarer Zeit dann Hinweise kriegen. Sehen wir noch die ursprünglich Sternenstaubzeichen.
Oder ist das der Bär durch mich duschte Staub, der dann in der Folge,
durch Prozessieren, Molekülwolken äh sich dann gebildet hat.
Ich sehe schon, da ist eine Menge Musik drin noch in so einem Thema
Aber ich würde sagen, für unser Gespräch haben wir erstmal alles ab äh geklappert. Vielen Dank für den tiefen Einblick in die ganze Entwicklung der äh Staubastronomie,
mit dem Begriff gehe ich jetzt äh hier mal neu raus. Das äh finde ich eigentlich ein sehr schönes äh Bild, weil's halt auch immer wieder zeigt, wie eigentlich auch so aus.
Ungerichteten Forschen, was erstmal vielleicht,
versucht irgendeine ganz einfache Frage zu beantworten und dann entwickelt man halt Technologien, kommt dann immer wieder ein Schritt weiter, dass man halt halt auf einmal an irgendeinen Punkt kommt, wo man sich denkt, ah okay, alles klar, das ist jetzt auch nochmal so ein
komplett neue Art und Weise auf das Universum zu schauen, um Fragen zu beantworten, die man vorher noch gar nicht hatte.
Genau, so sehe ich das und ich bin sehr glücklich drüber, dass ich da einen wichtigen Teil dazu beitragen konnte.
Ist ja auch ein Astrid nach ihm benannt worden, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne. Das ist ja schon mal eine gewisse Ehre. Vielen Dank Herr Grün.
Und natürlich vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Ihr wisst, bald geht's wieder weiter.